journée entre Nakamura et par avion
comment tu vas Kévin
re-saluce tout ça va très bien on s'est
quitté il y a un instant hein bah alors
j'accuse un petit peu le coup quand même
je viens de me faire avoir mon petit
poulain à Blue satorof n'a pas tenu le
choc contre l'expérimenté ouest les
sauts et je trouve que sur le match la
victoire de de ouest les sceaux est
pleinement méritée même si elle me fait
mal au cœur et je te vois sourire
je suis green quoi c'est normal c'est
normal et évidemment non mais ok le
match en vrai n'était pas clair
mais saut en placable un seau il est
vraiment très fort il commet quasiment
pas d'erreurs il est très très dur à
battre en match et dans des conditions
en plus comme on l'a si bien répété
c'est vrai qu'il était pas très bien
installé et jouer comme au café du
commerce et franchement respect et
maintenant on va avoir le grand Nakamura
quand même parce que c'est je favoris ce
type de match le speedchait 5 + 1 3 + 1
1 + 1 et on dirait qu'il a été inventé
pour lui ce speechestre quoi donc par
Aviane qui est quand même normalement
bah voilà le joueur le plus faible qui
nous frappe peut-être mentir mais en
tout cas c'est la seule tête d'affiche
on dit pas qu'il est inconnu c'est un
grand maître à plus de 2600 mais il est
vraiment normalement pour ce niveau-là
beaucoup plus juste que les autres donc
voilà on va voir combien de points il va
faire dans dans ce match est-ce qu'il va
réussir à inquiéter Nakamura ça va être
très dur on va voir j'y crois pas trop
en fait en vrai
Nakamura c'est vraiment le
le meilleur joueur de la compétition
avec Carlson
donc à moi qui est quand même quatre
titres de speed Championship
[Musique]
en sa carrière et c'est le monstre c'est
le monstre du circuit qui joue contre un
joueur qui s'est qualifié donc un joueur
qui est très très fort qui est qui est
un genre professionnel aussi venant de
Russie David paranian qui a 2600 hello
feed qui est bien sûr très très fort
mais bon Nakamura c'est juste c'est
juste c'est juste beaucoup plus fort il
y a quasiment 200 points à vélo d'écart
entre les deux et 200 points qui
comptent on va dire que tous les 50
points et l'eau c'est un autre monde
donc là il y a finalement
niveau grand maître ou quatre étoiles
niveau grand mètre d'écart donc ça va
être quand même
très très dur ça va être très très dur
mais ok bon par avion qui est là qui va
faire qui va faire qui va faire son
match donc Nakamura qui vient d'écrire
dans le chat est-ce qu'on commence
[Musique]
à aller on va dire qu'on commence en 20
secondes le match donc l'arbitre a
changé c'est pas le même qu'avant c'est
pas la même voix donc eux ils peuvent
changer nous non
dans tous les cas ça commence de suite
et voilà
donc en plus ma caméra
je vois ah mais c'est pas lui qui stream
je pense c'est quelqu'un qui est stream
à sa place
j'imagine il a commencé avec A3 au
premier coup Nakamura il veut faire
tilter par Aviane donc c'est c'est
plutôt une bonne stratégie Kevin je te
propose qu'on
établisse rapidement le terme de nos
Paris bien sûr
[Musique]
du coup
ça fait pas
qu'est-ce qu'on comment
on fait ça aujourd'hui
l'enchère sur le match et après
l'enchère par 7 pardon la partie je
oublie vous la mettre je suis désolé je
l'ai mise pour moi et pas pour vous j'ai
oublié de le mettre sur
bien vu que
qui vous teste là je teste voir si vous
êtes si vous suivez la partie a commencé
par A3 je suis désolé je voulais faire
rapide je vous la fin d'accélérer A3 de
la part de Maka qui
tombe dans une sorte de 6 cylindres
avec un temps de plus parce que du coup
il a joué le coup avec les Blancs
un petit une sorte d'anglaise après du
coup l'anglais c'est une Sicilienne à
l'envers si l'adversaire répond E5 voilà
donc c'est assez clair je pense pour
c'est ça
du coup Kevin comment on fait un peu de
Paris B5 je parlais noir waouh on a dit
à vaxtouf que c'était trop facile de
prendre Nakamura parce qu'il y a
normalement un écart de niveau très
important on va voir parce que
moi je te chanteront mais j'ai vu les
réactions de la caméra sur le B5 de
parabian il était mort de rire au début
et il avait la tête du c'est quoi ce
coup de Guignol et
en vrai B5 ça empêche cavaler ces quatre
ça menace à 5
je trouve pas qu'elle soit tout à fait
stupide c'est un bon coup alors on va
quand même noter que paravient c'est un
TOP grand maître qui a pas loin 2600
euros c'est un super super joueur ah non
c'est un autre monde déjà voilà
mais entre les deux joueurs il y a quand
même deux ou trois mondes quand même
mais c'est quand même un super super
joueur donc le coup B5 de parabian enfin
je veux dire par là il va pas jouer des
coups
on va dire stupide c'est un très très
bon journée chacun a juste à rétablir un
petit peu ça avant de continuer parce
que moi je t'ai coupé mais j'ai vu ma
gamin mort de rire sur B5 et ça ça m'a
fait ça m'a fait rire moi aussi mais il
lui a mis un gros décad dans la tête
quand même thématique
alors excuse-moi tu disais par rapport
au Paris
les petits Paris qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
alors peut-être
sur le score de paravient exactement
alors il y a Oscar total du match
alors
après ça fait combien de parties à peu
près on est sur à peu près 25 26 parties
habituellement ouais quelque chose comme
ça
ouais donc c'est à toi de parler en
premier je pense non vu que moi j'avais
dit j'avais dit saut
sur chaque section on va on va parler
une fois chacun
[Musique]
on dit un score et que le plus près
gagne plutôt que de faire plus et moins
parce que c'est moins
c'est vrai c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
le plus près gagné
et puis par exemple
dis un truc par un pour le score total
je vais le noter pour voir si tu veux ce
que tu dis
je te laisse
au total
alors
je vais dire plus près
4 et demi
donc c'est pas
je sais pas ce que tu veux je t'avais
dit 4h
est-ce qu'on garde j'ai pas pu dire 4
parce que je savais que c'était le truc
j'ai failli parce que je me suis dit
c'est marrant de te bloquer tu vois
juste pour voir ta tête
c'est à peu près ce qu'il doit faire
enfin c'est à peu près juste ok donc 4
et demi pour toi
et moi je veux dire 4
OK
du coup en cinq plus une ou une plus une
bien je vais commencer moi vu qu'on fait
par l'inverse
donc il faut que je sois quand même moi
j'avais marqué est-ce qu'on compte les
nuls
on continue
donc oui je les ai compté parce que
sinon j'aurais pas pu dire 4 et demi
je veux dire deux en une inscriptions
[Musique]
voilà mais il peut trop dans la fin
donc tu as dit deux
donc je peux pas dire deux c'est ça
donc je vais dire
OK et après moi je vais dire après ça
tourne
1/2 il faut que j'arrive au 4 et demi en
trois plus cinq ou cinq plus un
[Musique]
je vais dire à demi aussi moi je veux
dire un
il faut que je passe moi il faut que je
sois cohérent ouais c'est pour ça que
j'essaie d'être cohérent sur l'ensemble
et en 5 + 8 aussi mais aussi voilà
cohérent
allez bon du coup les paris sont faits
et du coup à chaque fois c'est à chaque
c'est comme d'hab
est-ce que tu veux faire 2 2 et le total
tu veux faire 4 ou qu'on garde la
cohérence jusqu'au bout et puis voilà
quoi ça marche allez donc du coup
maintenant on va on va passer à cette
partie
il va falloir que par Aviane il en mette
des buts ça m'arrange il met des buts
quand même
des petites nulles
donc on a dit attends j'ai dit 1 5 1 5 1
1 2
en tout cas c'est pas dans celle-là que
qu'il domine le plus notre ami Pavard
quand même parce que
si il en gagne deux souvenirs en fait
il faut qu'il fasse
en fait c'est un joueur qui
qui peut qui peut bien ça dépend comment
il résiste à la pression parce que quand
il va avoir les bulles défilés si elles
arrivent
ça peut être chaud
tu vois qu'il est pas encore réussi à
parler sur son développement avec les
noirs et encore un cavalier en B7 c'est
un peu passer chaque côté mais le pion
blanc est quand même plus dangereux que
le pion noir
bah oui oui il y a la pression il y a la
pression
il y a une pression sur sur F7 sur le
développement et aussi maintenant autant
il y a il y a une minute 20 d'avance
dans ce match je vous rappelle qu'il y a
toujours un incrément il y a une seconde
parcours à chaque fois
ça va être dur puis bon il y a le pion
des cartes qui va prochainement tomber
qui peut plus sortir ma position est
déjà presse c'est pour ça qu'il a 25
secondes parce que là il a eu vraiment
des problèmes dans cette première partie
avec le petit coin 3
qui est qui est focus il a envie de
gagner ce match et je pense qu'il a
envie de bien gagner ce match d'ailleurs
et en tout cas j'étais sur le zoom avant
le début du lancement et Nakamura a
demandé on commence quand on commence
quand
il a un train à prendre
et l'entrée intéressante en tout cas ça
t'affiche moi j'aime bien tu vois le on
va dire l'ogre vraiment
et d'ailleurs il s'appelle David
parvient donc c'est pas mal en plus que
j'ai trouvé
David le truc Goliath j'avais pas assez
exprès
David paradis
IDE ce David contre Goliath on va voir
si dans son article il me fait il me
s'il me il me fera confiance
parce que là c'est clair que Nakamura
c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment le monstre de la
compétition qui est très très dur
apparaît
pour cette première partie qui prend
clairement ce matin au sérieux
là ce qui marche pas non
attention
[Musique]
c'est juste c'est juste un femme
et je pense que plus la cadence plus la
cadence
on va dire et rapide réduit généralement
plus les plus il est fort
on essaye il a bien négocier le virage
quand même par Aviane
et là finalement bah écoute il s'en est
pas mal sorti
[Musique]
et bien bien bouger dans le Bullet
finalement je suis pas mécontent d'avoir
montré enfin tu vois je regarde ce que
j'ai dit j'ai mis un et demi je me dis
que tu es au dessus en bullade bon on
verra mais
des problèmes de foulée quoi il met les
cavaliers sur la tête tomber dans la
première donc
un petit peu fait peur dans cette partie
ouais il a pas été si souvent que ça
clairement bah lui a mis des pièces sur
la tête par avion à un moment et on a vu
que Naka bah ça faisait peur comme à
tout le monde mais bon il défend une
vitesse folle quoi donc
il s'en sort quand même très très
facilement
là
il peut il peut battre plusieurs fois
son adversaire c'est à dire qu'il est
l'occasion déjà de se retrouver mieux
parce que c'est très bien joué aux
échecs et même s'il est mal bah il
faudra lui passer dessus et le finir
aussi parce qu'il va se défendre bec et
ongles
avec H4 donc la variante à la mode
d'ailleurs
et puis par avion préparer son match
quand même donc pour jouer contre
on voit que son hello à 3000 dans ce
registre ça veut dire que il s'est bien
joué quand même sur Internet
c'est quand même c'est quand même assez
assez incroyable et Fatou qui qui est
revenu parmi nous salut à toi
hello hello
alors Fatou j'en ai sorti une bonne tout
à l'heure je pense que tu aurais été
fier de moi ce que tu l'avais écouté
mais malheureusement tu étais pas là
et en fait le prénom de paraguenne c'est
David et du coup j'ai un petit peu
comparé cette rencontre avec avec David
contre Goliath et j'étais assez fier de
moi je sais pas ce que tu en penses
c'est pas un free porn pas sûr parce
qu'il y a souvent tombé un tourbécile
qui peut qui peut arriver
le développement le sous-développement
des pièces noires du coup on essaie
d'ouvrir le centre parce que nous on
peut roter en un coup donc on va essayer
de lui foncer dessus et de la son
parvient s'il veut bouger Naka il est
obligé de l'agresser quand même cela pas
le choix prendre l'initiative alors en
effet c'est David qui gagne dans la
légende
ça reste qu'une légende mais si ta vie
de gaz et ben en tout cas je gagnerai
plus de ça parce que moi j'ai parié ah
non j'ai peur de tous les seuls
[Musique]
il faut que
il faut que David gagne pour moi quoi
bon là il faut éviter d'en prendre 4 qui
lâche la partie après qu'elle va laisser
deux donc la dame prend B6 qui est des 4
ou dans ma 4 échec pour la même il est
faire cavalier
noir excusez-moi je vous ai dit
n'importe quoi
je pensais que c'était n'a qu'à moi qui
avait les blancs une petite seconde ok
cavalier des cadres du coup comment on
va continuer est-ce qu'il va laisser 5
au roi des 7
c'est quand même des lignes assez
solides pour les pour les blancs
pour lui quand même il peut travailler
après le pion on sait après il faut pas
se mettre mal au temps
en japonais ce serait ouf
j'avais pas vu ce motif et carreaux il
veut piquer le fou
vraiment en termes de gestion du temps
ce qui me faisait un peu peur dans ce
match je trouve qu'il répond présent
enfin si tu veux pas ridicule sur ce
sujet d'accord
6 et après tout c'est un cavalier 4
c'est normal
c'est bien il fait une bonne partie par
avion là il va peut-être il va peut-être
lui prendre quelque chose on va voir
j'avais bossé un moment donné ça et
c'est très très compliqué pour les deux
couleurs il y en a de partout
d'ailleurs ça m'avait un petit peu un
peu écœuré parce que j'aime pas les
positions ou tout se jouent dans la
théorie j'aime bien pouvoir essayer de
jouer aux échecs des fois et j'aime pas
les vraiment trop forcer comme ça ça me
paraît il domine là sous franchement il
fait une partie de très haut niveau là
on avait dit que c'était un genre de
haut niveau mais là il est en train de
sortir une grosse partie une grosse
partie je sais pas si on a quatre
là j'ai du mal à comprendre il va
trouver un accord il est très très fort
pour cela mais quelle va être le contre
jeu
mais il se fait secouer
je suis pas sûr
je suis pas sûr qu'il répète derrière
on a envie de jouer B3 ici
je pense
c'est un coup très sérieux il fait une
super partie j'adore les coups que je
joue parano
[Musique]
U5 voilà bah ça fait une structure un
peu
pas terrible malgré le pion de plus on
le ressent pas du tout comme ça tous les
pions sont faibles pour C4
après après reprendre
il le sait parce que logique
à 4 et du coup peut-être qu'il veut
jouer 8
je sais pas comment il va la jouer
comment tours
B8 en contre
je peux partir avec ma tour en B8 quand
tu dors notre proposition peut-être plus
sérieuse cavalier h G5 cavalier FG5
pardon
pour ça qu'il a voulu faire peut-être il
va jouer tout raciste là dessus
et du coup mon coeur contrôle tout les
cases du cavalier et c'est très dur
après j'ai l'impression c'est parce que
je peux jouer pour des 6 choses comme ça
tu as du mal
à ramenerys
peut-être tout simplement
j'ai oublié de couper le zoom c'est pour
ça qu'il t'a entendu
une sacrée poubelle quand même
que mon Roi peut passer par des trois
bouger 4
[Musique]
parce que là il se dit que c'est une
belle opportunité et cette partie faut
pas qu'il la perte parce que vu comme il
a il a fait mal
même et même cavalier C5 c'est pas
ridicule qui avalé ces cinq non plus
[Musique]
KS et 5 on laisse le jeu mais bon on a
toujours des 7 tours alors souvent
souvent quand même dans le parti quand
on a le choix avec plein de bons coups
ben c'est souvent là que des fois on
pêche et on fait des
erreurs et
du coup en plus il y a aussi le fait de
jouer quand on a qu'un vous savez le
fait de jeu contre un joueur qui est
vraiment fort il va psychologiquement et
ben ça nous ça nous posait problème tout
à l'heure j'ai vu par avion qui secouait
la tête genre tu es pas pas sûr de ce
qui se passait alors que ma caméra à lui
il est quand même plutôt que général
généralement très confiant c'est parti
bien sûr donc on va voir un peu souvent
plus payé que le joueur pessimiste donc
il faut l'être
un pelage
bon il le savait de toute façon que
c'était l'idée de Tours
cavaliers aussi suivra
quand même c'est pas
c'est pas la joie
bon complètement gagnant maintenant mais
comment je gagne tour G7 roi F5
on en a assez c'est limite là
le 4 le 4 gagne
a peut-être pas ah si le cas de gagnant
prends mes trois barrières il a quand
même une tour de moins
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça tourne
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
encore gagnant mec
qui
[Musique]
blender le blender bon il a encore un
pion de plus c'est
pas encore perdu mais il a quand même
bien craqué il aurait pu juste manger la
tour c'était fini il reste 10 secondes à
la pendule
qui va qui va essayer de mieux en moins
au moins deux minutes et peut-être
gagner un noir
recycléaire ça devrait aller quand même
là si il se dépêche
4 qui a l'air quand même pas mal
la tour en un coup quoi c'est incroyable
[Musique]
quoi
c'est ça
[Musique]
franchement il a fait une super partie
partie niveau super GM
il méritait pas même la nul c'est pas
mérité mais là la perdre c'est ça
un peu
optimiste quand même il va faire
6 ou la feuille tomber
tu étais complètement gagnant et du coup
c'était quoi ton gagnant et du coup
tu veux la jouer alors que tu es plus
gagnant quoi tu vois ou elle a quand
même fait nul mine de rien déjà pour
qu'il soit pas cagoule parce qu'il est
censé marquer 4 et demi
j'ai fait les deux côtés c'est ça donc
maintenant par avion pour moi pendant
une heure il peut plus gagner
par rapport à mon pari il a appuyé son
crédit
et c'est ça il peut faire encore une
nulle mais c'est tout ça va être dur
quand même parce que là la cas il peut
quand même blender et puis pareil un bon
joueur
[Musique]
là il a fait une partie extraordinaire
mais il gagne je pense que il tient il
tient bien le pari quoi tu vois alors on
va raconter parce que là on nous demande
le pari ce qu'on a fait en gros on n'a
pas parier sur sur un joueur chacun
parce que bah évidemment Naka va gagner
enfin en tout cas je pense que c'est
assez clair pour pour nous on a parié
juste sur le score de paravient dans les
trois sets ainsi que dans le score final
et du coup moi j'ai parié sur dans le
premier set en 5 + 1 qui marquait pas
plus d'un point et Kevin a parié un et
demi et du coup celui qui est le plus
proche de ça et Ben et ben gagne le 7 en
3 plus une j'ai aussi mis un et demi et
en deux en une non en trois petits j'ai
mis un contre un et demi Kevin en une
plus une j'ai mis deux contre un et demi
qui est vide encore une fois et en
totale j'ai mis 4 contre 4,5
à Charles bah c'est ouest les saut qui a
gagné pour mon plus grand désarroi
malheureusement
[Musique]
deux fois et après il en fait il était
dans le dernier set
d'accord
j'en ai une aussi mais des fois je mets
pas de la bière
[Rires]
bon parti un peu délirante ça ressemble
à une Anglaise gros B avec un cavalier 7
supra bizarre
encore une fois donc c'est ça qui fait
un peu peur il fait un petit peu des
coups comme ça il veut troll en Nakamura
ce que de toute façon avec les Blancs
vous pouvez après prendre à trois et un
choix et après vous prenez les Noirs
donc pour lui ça change que dalle quoi
vous voyez hein
l'idée c'est comme il troll un petit peu
qu'on a quand même parier sur le score
de par avion et ben j'ai été un peu un
peu dur avec par avion et j'ai peur que
de
j'ai joué pour le 4 et demi jouer pour
plus et du coup parce que
là en fait j'étais un pain qui au départ
mais parabian il a montré des belles
qualités il avait super bien joué
d'ailleurs en gestion du temps et quand
il s'est retrouvé gagnant
il a voulu assurer le gain mais jusqu'à
le trouver complètement parce que là on
aurait gagné sous forme plus cette
partie mais on se le resterait peut-être
pas créé tu vois mais il a complètement
démoli en allemand
il a éclaté mais je pense que plus ça va
s'accélérer plus ça va être dur pour
pour par avion qu'est-ce qu'il a vu j'ai
cinq cavaliers F5 six joue d'un E5 il y
a fou aussi gf6 foudé 6 enferme madame
c'est ça qui l'a vu
c'est intéressant ce que tu racontes
échec
foulard puis on prend fou des 6 c'est la
dame elle est enfermée du coup a priori
je ne peux pas jouer cette séquence là
aussi d'autres cours à regarder comme CD
mais bon il y a toujours des fous des 6
fois incroyable
je pense qu'il faut reculer un bail ça
c'est ce qui fait il va vivre altar ok
ok il est depuis 2006 mais il est en
train de jouer pour
non là je comprends pas qu'elle prend
des cinq il a sûrement vu quelque chose
il prend comme ça il y avait les deux
qui étaient possibles
parce que ça m'avait l'air bien sûr
qu'elle va les prendre là
H4 donc c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
après la paravient a été très créé il a
été dans la baston hagnaka et peut-être
qu'il est foutu maintenant ou en
difficulté énorme mais cette partie qui
n'a pas gagné ça peut faire mal au moral
quand même honnêtement c'est sûr c'est
sûr comme ça
[Musique]
ça va pas être facile de lui en piquer
quand on a regardé enfin tu étais pas là
enfin si tu étais là-bas
on sait plus
hier dans le match qu'on a regardé
où en fait les joueurs il faut les
battre plusieurs fois pour les battre
franchement c'est assez incroyable
moi en tout cas là ça va être dur parce
que le centre blanc va commencer à
avancer et casser les cases les belles
cases du cavalier des cavaliers
des schémas cavaliers F3 E4 peut-être 4
directement si cavalier Descartes est
impossible à cause de Dam da qui
enferment le cavalier des cartes c'est
terriblement
quand vous n'avez pas de pion au centre
et bien les cavaliers on passe 15 pour
eux en fait au centre vous voyez le fait
de prendre le centre avec les Blancs ça
te permet de donner des cases à nos
pièces et là maintenant pas de pions et
au final dès qu'il mette un cavalier au
centre et ben ils peuvent plus après ils
peuvent plus rentrer à la maison quoi
qui va arriver ben c'est hyper hyper dur
à avoir
donc là il a plus de coup par avion
c'est pour ça qu'il réfléchi c'est il
s'est vraiment trompé en essayant de
mettre la pression cavalier F5 c'était
un coup de génie et il a enchaîné sur
Dame des trois par un coup complètement
à côté
donc voulons mettre la pression c'est
normal on peut pas le blâmer il est
obligé de mettre la pression un joueur
du style de Nakamura il l'a très bien
fait avec les blancs mais les deux
parties avec des Noirs sont beaucoup
moins bien évidemment puisque là tout à
l'heure il avait vraiment un gros retard
autant et là c'est pareil c'est en train
de se de très mal se passer
comment on joue du coup là
l'occasion il a eu quelle occasion et je
pense que de la tour et après vous
pouvez donner bah je sais pas ce qu'il a
cru non mais il a posé
devant quoi
B4 de Nakamura qui veut jouer cavalier à
6 celui de A3 très probablement
on est foutu déjà
cavalier à 6 A3
avec les blancs en premier coup et que
tu perds en 11 coups c'est quand même un
petit problème
terrible et je pense que plus ça va être
comme ça plus qu'un camouraï va-t-il il
va il va le rendre fou en fait je pense
qu'il va le rendre fou moi
pendant 60 parties
B3 avec les blancs tout le temps tout le
temps tu t'entraîner et tout le temps la
même chose
et
du coup
[Musique]
à la fin en fait il retourne le cerveau
quoi juste mais sur la mesure sur la
même truc qui te rend défaut
insupportable franchement si jouer à
caméra ouvert je pense auparavant c'est
complètement fou
il faudrait pas
il sait qu'il a la télé il sait qu'on le
regarde il sait que sur sa chaîne aussi
et ben il le suivent et donc F4 cavalier
prend en F2 je pense sur ma planche à 3
me fout des deux il va perdre le
cavalier ici
c'est fini
c'est terminé donc cette partie là ça va
être bien à cas ça va faire deux et demi
à un demi
je sais pourquoi je croyais que le
cavalier D3 dames prend des trois et
avec avaler B2
voilà ça c'est terrible parce que bien
sûr il y a deux 5 0 5
pourquoi il continue
il pourra abandonner il a 3 2 secondes
contre 2 minutes avec une dame de moins
il se chauffe il s'échauffe par Aviane
je pense qu'il est un petit thé Nakamura
est mort de rire je pense qu'il a un
petit et
la partie d'avant qu'il a perdu je pense
que clairement
clairement lui a clairement
sur le côté et qu'on joue avec les cases
blanches à gauche
avec les cases blanches à gauche
tu mâles ton échiquier en fait
je vois l'idée
[Musique]
du coup les rocks pas dans le même sens
etc ça fait ça fait du bas gain de Naka
et là c'est cher c'est cher est-ce
qu'avec les blancs il va réussir à
remettre une pression aussi importante
ça va être dur avec les Blancs
je suis pas sûr que le C3 soit fait
exprès
c'est cavalier c'est trois je pense qui
a été qui a été joué si c'est ça
c'est
4 ouais il vient de jouer ces trois je
pense qu'il a pas fait exprès non il a
pas fait exprès je l'ai vu à la caméra
il est bug il est gay et essayer et du
coup il se retrouve un peu moins bien
avec les Blancs directement
un gars un gars c'est mimi qu'est-ce
qu'il fait c'est vraiment un gag et par
avion qui coupe et quantité le match il
y a juste de commencer
je pense que ce match va va être long je
pense que ce match va être très long
alors est-ce que je vais décoller de mes
0,5 à un moment tu vois la question
c'est c'est ça mais écoute moi ça me va
très bien il avait fait la super partie
mais bon là
parce que
parce que là effectivement
là c'est difficile
ok bon après c'est pas grave il a les
blancs donc avec les Blancs on peut tous
permettre il a fait un mauvais coup mais
là tout est rentré dans l'ordre en fait
tu vois moi je te parle je te parle pas
de vraiment de ça en fait je parle
surtout du côté psychologique bien sûr
je suis d'accord avec toi oui première
partie ça fait démolir la deuxième
partie il le massacre et il rate un coin
intermédiaire et il a presque et au
moment où c'est vraiment archi archi
gagnant même pour un joueur amateur
qu'on a gagné c'est terminé et même
Fatou contre maca elle a gagné quoi tu
vois
mais par contre par contre après la
deuxième partie la troisième partie il
peut on dit coup sur un H3
il continue 20 coups une dame de moi ça
montre un tilt et puis là il rit enfin
chaque partie il y a un truc quoi chaque
partie il y a
5 sketch quoi par contre au niveau du
Time c'est pas mal ce qu'il fait c'est
le seul point positif après il faut
qu'il
reste en phase avec tout ça c'est ça
va les prendre aussi mais
presque mais presque parce que bon il y
a quand même damsé un d'un point B2 qui
peut arriver derrière mais voyez
en fait ici il y a G6 déjà première
chose qui permet d'attaquer la dame de
déclouer et manger la tour ici mais il y
a aussi
pas mal aussi il y a tout emprise donc
là pris dans un système n'est pas
possible dans cette position donc
attention quand même parce que
je sais pas si c'est possible ou pas
possible parce que cavalier aussi tu
fais quoi faut aussi tout aussi
c'est dur à calculer ce genre de
variante
en fait peut-être 3 D8
en fait
dès que tu fais tout reprendre j'insiste
ah tu te reprends dans cette reprise
ligne parce que c'est en force et
calculer aussi je pense qu'il est pas
sûr mais qui se dit bon on verra tu vois
enfin il calcule très bien c'est pas
possible
chaque fois c'est un
Sketchup et la barre qui descend tout en
bas et franchement
j'y croyais pas du tout
j'avais envie de payer pour voir
deux mais en fait j'ai le problème de la
3 pour tout le temps quoi
en fait juste toujours
après taureau 2 je crois
peut-être dans F5 dames ces deux vite
fait
même celle-là elle a hyper chance
on lui fait confiance et voyez en fait
par avion quand il rentre dans un truc
comme ça parce que psychologiquement en
fait et ben je pense qu'il est il est
déjà perdu quoi tu vois parce que tu
rentres pas là-dedans en fait en temps
normal tu vois ça ça va être la ronde un
je pense pas qu'il aurait le sort
j'imagine les efforts de par avion pour
se qualifier
je me souviens de mon match contre
Nakamura où j'avais joué environ 60
parties
et ben j'avais perdu le premier jour à
34 0 un truc comme ça et le deuxième
jour il m'a rectifié et il me remettait
peut-être 15-0 et au bout de 15 0 dans
le deuxième jour donc environ 50 0 pour
un Nakamura j'ai pas honte de dire que
50 € contre ma caméra les gars c'est
juste le meilleur joueur du monde sur
Internet
et du coup
à la fin j'étais un petit le thé c'est à
dire que je veux plus vraiment je sais
conventionnel dans le sens que je jouais
hyper agro et puis la partie où j'ai
gagné et ben j'ai fait un truc du genre
un fougère qui attaque le cavalier il me
fait H3 fou bouge j'ai fait cavaler
l'étranger 4 un peu en mode tilt parce
que bah c'est bon il faut l'agresser
quoi sinon tu gagnes pas quoi et je l'ai
maté voilà voilà et du coup ben là si tu
veux le match c'est la peine de
commencer mais quand même je sens un peu
une frustration comme celle que j'ai
vécu dans dans ce match là avec là où il
balance cavaler progressiste tout ça
pour au final
tu vois comme si tu sais qu'en fait de
toute façon voilà et tu veux du jeu quoi
du hasard
et de quoi après il tente 3 minutes et
Nakamura qui fait sa tête de
genre sérieux et tout mais en fait
ce match va être très très long je pense
au parabian ça va très très long
au final je vais gagner deux parties et
fait peut-être de nul et éperdu en tout
son compte les deux jours environ 65
parties je pense que je vais faire 3 à
65 un truc comme ça
ce qui est un bon ratio ça fait 1/20
c'est pas si mal en vrai en vrai si vous
voulez votre Nakamura 1 sur 20 c'est pas
mal
[Musique]
moi j'ai déjà vu mettre plusieurs fois
moi je l'ai vu mettre 13 euros à McDo
Nakamura
à
le mec il est beaucoup trop fort en fait
c'est mis 10 € à faire toutes mes 20
euros enfin même plus quoi bien sûr bien
sûr après ça dépend de la forme du
joueur aussi en face et comment il
réagit au défaite
il se retrouve avec 5 secondes au temps
contre trois minutes n'arrive pas à
trouver des mais non seulement il est
hyper fort mais en plus cette difficulté
à trois H3 tu vois il est horrible en
fait
il est complètement horribles
de NACA mais il a pas gagné encore gagné
on peut pas lui enlever
8 là tranquille
il a joué ça
il a fait la tête
après une partie en manque là ouais ça
va arriver en Bullet en Bullet donc
cloud c'est sûr que ça va arriver
remplie c'est bon il est il essaie
encore de tu vois mais là tu vois ah je
crois et j'ai 4 il fait la même
est vraiment pas très conventionnel
en fait souvent il y a un plan avec G4
c'est robe pour aller piquer le fou donc
là il a essayé d'être créatif partout
d'avant malheureusement
c'est bizarre ça
dernière partie avant la pause qui fera
peut-être du bien à part avion il a
besoin de d'une petite pause
à la pause il aura pas gagné une partie
s'il arrive pas à faire quelque chose là
et c'est dur là ce qui lui arrivait il a
fait une tellement bonne partie il a
fait une partie de ouf et il a pas été
payé là en fait c'est le système
carpoque c'est 5 dans l'anglaise et un
des plans c'est d'amener le pion qui en
G3 normalement en G4 et du coup ben là
on a une meilleure config je crois on a
amélioré la ligne de base
mais en fait
il est malade parce qu'il sait que le
mec en face va se préparer et du coup ça
stratégie c'est juste le jeu de la merde
tu vois je vois des trucs pas théoriques
et c'est le sortir complètement mais
comme ça avec les blanc il fait pas ça
quand même avec les Blancs il retombe
comme à peu près sur les pattes sur ses
pattes à chaque deux anglaises
intéressantes et du coup il va balancer
le D4 alors est-ce que les joueurs ont
aussi la caméra alors oui et non tof tof
parce qu'en fait on est on est tous sur
zoom si tu veux et on peut se voir mais
pendant le match je pense pas que
Nakamura il s'amuse à ouvrir zoom pour
la tête de son adversaire
je sais pas si c'est autorisé je pense
que il y a rien qui
qui est dit à ce niveau là
les arbitres et ben ils ont une caméra
frontale
pour voir les joueurs celles qu'on vous
propose sur sur twitch il y a aussi deux
caméras qui sont derrière les joueurs
qui sont réservés aux arbitres pour
vérifier qu'il ne trichent pas et qui a
pas de problème là-dessus qui sont seuls
dans la pièce etc et il y a aussi le
l'écran des deux joueurs qui est partagé
du coup sur zoom donc du coup bah là
tout est vraiment sous contrôle donc
voilà voilà
on peut tout jouer avec les Blancs
vraiment donc oui la vérifier vite fait
souvent en fait il fait une sorte
d'anglaise c'est vraiment les schémas de
l'anglaise donc finalement il connaît
quand même
tout cela et puis il aime bien s'amuser
un petit peu à regarder la théorie c'est
il faut pas oublier qu'on a d'être un
streamer un joueur de Blitz
c'est aussi un des meilleurs mondiaux en
partie lente et du coup ils connaissent
ces joueurs là ex ouais plein de choses
quoi voilà après les mimiques qui fait
Nakamura c'est pas pour tilter
l'adversaire c'est plus parce que ben il
est en string il est là et puis voilà il
fait un peu le chaud quoi mais
voilà c'est ça il s'amuse et puis c'est
un personnage maintenant tu vois mais
c'est plus pour ça mais après en IRL il
faut aussi des fois
donc au final bah écoute c'est standard
quand même je sais Nakamura
tu verras pas généralement un mec comme
Aronian faire ses médicaments
tu vois parce que bah il est plus il est
moins dans le sens de de faire le buzz
de tout ça quoi c'est pas vraiment
style la même chose quoi
[Musique]
il est un peu à part finalement c'est le
joueur le plus exubérant
à part c'est même le seul je pense dans
le circuit qui qui se permet d'être
comme ça parce que bah c'est un streamer
il est pas apprécié j'ai plein de choses
et du coup il profite un peu de son
image pour tout ça quoi mais après bon
voilà j'aime beaucoup les blancs dans
cette position j'aime beaucoup les
blancs
est-ce que tu penses qu'en grande va
arriver
ça commence à chauffer ou B2 il place
ses pièces il préfère garder le roi au
milieu mais grand pour arriver avec des
F4
donc il l'attend en tournant avec un
rock
il n'y a pas besoin de se précipiter
puis je pense qu'il va laisser le temps
de paraviane s'écouler parce qu'on
commence à sentir un paravent un peu
plus émoussé qu'en début de match où il
était très rapide
et là il est moins inspiré dans cette
position assez créa il a pas envie de se
faire se faire bouger mais comment
comment gérer
la poussée F4 c'est déjà pas évident
on peut pas faire B5 véritablement avec
la casser 6 c'est difficile
il y a
ça peut exciter un cas bien sûr il y a
F4
c'est que bah j'attaque un peu toutes
les pièces
la possibilité
mais on peut y aller directement aussi
ouais
il a 2586 hellofield il a été à plus de
26 pendant longtemps
très très vite il est mondial
numéro 261
donc ces gammes un monstre mais
[Musique]
les top player donc c'est dur
quand même
et surtout en biais thérapie c'est top 3
il se fait plaise
c'est extrêmement difficile les pièces
vous avez vu tu as pas vraiment vraiment
de
coordination le roi humble c'est
compliqué vous avez vu un Nakamura il a
gardé son son roi au centre
dans cette position à sec extrême le roi
de l'adverse r était lui aussi au centre
dès que l'adversaire
c'est lui foncer dessus
tu as pas trop envie d'ouvrir la colonne
g tu vois je pense ça va
F6 qui est sûrement aussi une grosse
menace il y a une minute à la pendule
pour par avion
et et
c'est très très mal maintenant
par avion
de voir la réaction de parabian il est
déjà prêt
après 45 minutes bien le moral est bien
entamé mais en fait dès la ronde dès la
deuxième partie en fait de la deuxième
va être très souvent dans les matchs
comme ça comme aussi
avec un un mais après moralement c'est
c'est pour ça que quand il a pas gagné
sa partie tout là avec une tour de enfin
une tour de plus qui volait en finale
c'est clair ce que dit regarde
[Musique]
entre Naka et paraviane donne
l'impression que ce dernier journal tu
as l'impression qu'il est qu'il est pas
bon en fait alors que ça reste un joueur
qui a quasiment 2600 c'est un TOP GM
c'est un super joueur mais en fait plus
l'écart est grand plus
on a l'impression qu'en fait c'est
facile quoi et c'est souvent comme ça
quand vous regardez des streamers hyper
forts
mais en fait le mec il est juste trop
fort enfin oui il y a ça se fait aussi
de la pression c'est-à-dire que c'est
comme au tennis quand je regardais les
meilleurs mondiaux allez on va dire
Djokovic la dalle et Federer avant quand
il joue un mec même du top 100 mondial
mais on va dire fin de Top 100 il met
une pression ils mettent ces jours là
une pression telle et une force dans la
balle et des coups précis que le mec est
complètement dépassé et c'est ce qui se
passe un petit peu avec parabian qui n'a
pas le temps de s'organiser parce que
Nakamura lui met tout le temps la
pression
alors que si nous on joue contre par
avia et ben on va on va vite comprendre
qu'en fait
ça serait la même histoire en fait
[Musique]
raison c'est un super joueur mais tout
le monde tout le monde est d'accord en
fait pour dire façon les grands matins
200600 c'est déjà un autre monde comme
je le disais mais tous les 53 il y a pas
ce système aux échecs mais pour
différencier les grands maîtres et entre
guillemets à 2500 et au niveau de Magnus
Carlsen ça n'a rien à voir c'est pas le
même jeu
déjà en 2007 c'est pas comme un 2006 et
elle a et après à 2007 j'ai envie de
dire tous les 20 30 points c'est un
autre c'est un cap quoi ça en fait des
histoires d'étoiles avec nous
c'est un truc de fou
le speech je trouve que c'est pas facile
à vivre franchement les mecs ils ont du
mérite parce que voilà petite perso ça
m'arrivait dans des Open si je perds
deux parties de suite je suis déjà tilté
parce que ça m'arrive pas quoi perdre
deux parties eux les mecs qui c'est une
machine à gagner quand même bon bah des
fois avoir un badrun même sur un match
ok sur sur internet en blitz ça fait
quand même mal à l'ego Malo moral
regarde nous avec stouf quand on va
faire des des Blitz etc quand ça se
passe mal on a quand même envie de
rimacher comme n'importe quel jour
amateur voilà c'est humain on a envie de
se battre on adore les échecs quoi
alors il y a une question intéressante
de l'exercice qui demande quelle est la
différence de niveau en fait entre
est-ce que le stream en fait le fait de
streamer est-ce que ça affecte ton jeu
donc on va répondre
plus tu as l'habitude de la de streamer
moins ça sera ton jeu quoi en fait moi
je dirais la pause normalement ils vont
s'arrêter là c'est sûr
du coup moi je dirais en fait que ça
dépend vraiment de de de toi en fait
parce que c'est vrai que moi en stream
j'ai tendance à lire énormément le chat
en fait je l'ai tout quasiment tout sauf
qu'on va tout est là et du coup elle me
fait remarquer que je regarde des choses
mais j'essaye vraiment d'être présent
sur le chat et de lire au maximum et de
répondre en fait interagir avec le chat
ce qui fait que du coup l'échiquier ben
je le je le vois Fatou est là évidemment
et ben les Ch'tis du coup je porte un
peu moins d'attention et du coup j'ai un
oeil aller un œil
sur les chéquier et du coup bah je joue
bien évidemment beaucoup moins bien
quand le stream que quand que quand je
stream pas quand le stream pas là je
pète focus je mets de la musique je suis
voilà je suis dans c'est différent il y
a des gens comme Naka comme aussi bah
j'ai vu aussi Kevin Birdy blindstream
que tout le monde connaît ici bien en
fait et ben le fait de streamer j'ai
l'impression que ça leur ça les motive
encore plus si vous voulez et ils
arrivent à être encore plus fort je
pense en stream que hors string et je me
demande si Naka est pas encore plus fort
en ce moment
mais je sais pas je peux pas vous dire
malheureusement c'est pareil pour qu'il
y a une bordure j'ai jamais vu jouer
hors stream mais dans tous les cas
il y a des joueurs qui ça les aide et
alors que moi ça me ça m'aide pas ça me
freine sans point j'en sais rien en fait
ça dépend comment tu le fais si tu le
fais en show etc focus pour faire le
maximum de résultats en mode détente
quoi c'est un petit peu différent voilà
après il faut dire aussi que c'est
différent quand tu abuses stream et
quand tu vois Nakamura je l'ai je les
compare parce qu'en fait quand tu vois
le chat chez eux et ben en fait ils ont
très souvent pas le temps de lire
tellement il y a de commentaires et du
coup bah ils ont
pas le temps de tout lire et du coup en
fait et ben ils sont beaucoup moins
focus sur le chat que
moi je le suis par exemple parce que moi
je peux tout dire parce que j'ai
beaucoup moins de messages que eux ils
ont tu vois et du coup enfin il y a un
peu tout mais c'est vrai que si je
streamais sans regarder chat et ben le
je pense que le stream perdrait un petit
peu d'intérêt parce que c'est un peu
moins drôle et que bah j'interagis pas
quoi et
bon je serai sûrement plus fort je rêve
sûrement quand même plus d'élo que ce
que j'ai là j'ai pas pris 2006 2007
quasiment tout le temps alors qu'à
l'époque quand j'étais hors stream j'ai
toujours dans les plus de 2007 donc
enfin quand tu vieillis souffle je
vieillis aussi ouais je vieillis
mais mais voilà tu vois c'est c'est ça
après ben le Fire stream c'est quoi
pourquoi tu stream pour divertir pour un
plaisir etc donc moi je pense qu'on s'en
fout un peu et moi je suis content de
faire ce que je fais en tout cas je
continuerai à faire ça donc je
continuerai à être nul ça c'est nul
non on dit modeste modeste voilà
parce que de chattes de tequila je pense
c'est plutôt chaude de vodka qui devrait
prendre par Aviane c'est plus dans le
dans le style de la maison
et donc les joueurs sont revus de la
pause je pense qu'on a raté la pause du
coup c'est pas très grave toute façon
moi je moi ça me va pas grave de toute
façon là en plus ça va assez vite il
reste 36 minutes donc ça va pas faire
beaucoup de parties sans doute 4 il
reste donc pour l'instant j'ai pas mal
dans le pari hyper bien s'ils font la
même et ben écoute je je paye parce que
j'avais voté sur un bah oui c'est c'est
donc il faut que par avion réussisse à
gagner une partie et là
elle a vu comment ça s'est passé tout à
l'heure
ça fait mal il l'aurait gagné celle-là
ça aurait été un tout autre match mais
vous savez c'est comme ça
aurait été complètement
différente d'une partie extraordinaire
c'est on a vu quelques très très belles
parties aujourd'hui la partie de
parabian contre Naka et monstrueuse et
une partie de Wesley Sow contre d'où ça
torov et aussi une Master Class
incroyable date d'où ça t'auras enfin un
moment tout peut gâcher sur la fin mais
c'était topissime complètement trois
parties pour nos cours
du coup ça devrait reprendre je pense
dans quelques instants
que c'est vrai que tout ce qu'on fait
avec tout faut aussi de streamer etc ça
nous donne pas mal d'idées en tout cas
pour ma part tu vois les parties qu'on
avait vu en random chaise des petits
délires etc bah ça donne plein
d'exemples pour les cours comme ça on
n'est pas obligé de piocher que dans les
livres on peut aussi créer nos propres
exemples et s'amuser avec ça et c'est
top
très agréable de créer soi-même
ambiances il y en a qu'un mort de rire
et par Aviane qui
menaca aujourd'hui je pense qu'il va il
va je pense que
a gagné aujourd'hui il va être
tranquille je pense aujourd'hui il va
pas trop s'inquiéter peut-être que pour
le prochain match il sera un peu plus
concerné on peut vous montrer d'ailleurs
le bracket du parcours savoir contre qui
les joueurs qualifiés donc il est pas
vraiment à jour parce que là on voit que
saut c'est qualifié il va affronter
Maxime va chez l'arabe le français en
quart de finale et du coup Nakamura
paravient le gagnant de ce match donc
probablement Nakamura affront à rognan
aussi en quart de finale les autres
quarts de finale sont déjà
sont déjà mis à jour vous voyez 45
carwana 10000 Rennes
Niall Sarine et donc voilà d'ailleurs
premier carnet final qui aura lieu du
coup demain
sur ce qu'on va faire
commenter sûrement par je crois que
c'était Sammy et moi-même
mais je ne sais pas
encore lequel va avoir le demain et je
ne sais pas encore à quelle heure ça
c'est un peu compliqué parce que ça va
dépendre des joueurs et des horreurs qui
vont se proposer
[Musique]
la french pour les carreau allez se la
faire coller sur la française
ça te dérange pas
comme vous préférez Kevin 30 secondes
chercher de l'eau parce que j'ai pas
tout à fait le droit donc
[Musique]
c'est pas tout à fait conventionnel ce
qui s'est passé
alors bon ce qui est normal c'est il a
donné son foodcas noir
l'objectif c'est de détruire normalement
la structure
mais là parviennent à réussir à garder
sa structure d'option alors dans H4 et
chaque G3 cavaliers projet 3 alors je
peux pas vous faire les flèches mais il
y a faux F2 vraisemblablement et sur
dame B4 j'ai C3 donc damage 4 et chaque
ici il y a un problème donc là il Caro
doit se poser des questions
parce que le cavalier n'a rien à faire
en G5 si vous voulez donc j'ai plus de
coup
ks5 ne marche pas il y a poussé 5 et sur
Damas 5 B4 du coup je suis bien embêté
avec mon histoire de cavalier c'est une
petite préparation qui vient mettre sans
doute parce que il a joué très très vite
je suis trop vite à soi du bluffant on
est dans un truc rigolo il s'est fait un
peu avoir un accord je pense par paraben
dans l'ouverture
bon c'est pas grave ici mais il s'est
fait un petit peu
avoir ça reste modeste on va très bon
avantage blanc quoi
[Musique]
il est à la rue alors il va réussir à
ramener ses pièces un jour hein
d'accords
et de grands rock et une position très
sérieuse alors est-ce qu'on échange les
dames et on est vraiment beaucoup mieux
dans la finale où est-ce qu'on joue ces
trois
pour garder la pression
il garde G3 c'est quand même belle
C3 si ça faisait plus confiance tu vois
peut-être il garderait les pièces la
logique de la position c'était quand
même plus C3 je pense cette position est
très agréable aussi hein
il se dit aussi peut-être qu'il a mon
pari à assuré stouf j'espère que mes
poulains en ce moment une petite nul
c'est pas si mal encore
l'école l'école Pro Évolution et chaque
avec paraviane elle est elle est mis à
malin elle est mis à mal pour le moment
qui est
il veut casser alors
comme choix mais il veut tout en fait
toute façon il veut gagner donc il joue
les risques maximum je pense que d'un
cas il veut il veut lui coller il veut
lui mettre un gros score
[Musique]
il veut lui mettre un gros score
apparemment
on peut jouer tous deux tours sans
risque ici
et pressécom
savoir quel est le score de leur
rencontre en 2020
bien sûr c'est intéressant
je pense que c'est pas une bonne idée
il faut quand même que je prenne une
décision en fait
C4
je vais mettre mon fou en C5 mais en
même temps j'ai toujours mon histoire de
pion
de pions j'ai trois à protéger
si je joue à 5 mon pion peut être vite
fait faible en 5
genre sur cavalier 6
et merci beaucoup Hélène pour ce raid
merci à toi alors les gars pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas la chaîne d'Hélène je
vous invite à aller la découvrir
très sympathique et en plus
elle aime beaucoup l'autre chorizo alors
ça pour le coup les gars c'est une très
très grande qualité je l'ai je l'ai
appris hier à mes dépenses et du coup
bah du coup maintenant il faut l'arrête
tout le temps les gars
ce matin
je sais que ça m'intéresse beaucoup ce
que je dis mais pour moi c'est bon sauf
non mais c'est tellement la vie en fait
c'est un truc de fou donc rien que pour
ça les gars allez sur ta chaîne lâchez
les follow lâchez tout
n'hésitez pas à demander l'adresse de
stouf pour lui envoyer des saucissons et
chorizo
le matin c'est violent non ça va je le
fais c'est une sorte de croque-monsieur
tu vois mais
de la place du jambon quoi ouais à
croquer
en plus il a des petites petites idées
de recettes là avec la pizza chorizo
ananas on sent l'association un peu
travaillée d'ailleurs
sa page mais très sympa c'est hyper
chill c'est vraiment dans la bonne
humeur tout le temps très sympathique
donc elle est elle découvrir aussi fait
beaucoup de bullets en ce moment
beaucoup de Bullet il se chauffe pas mal
Tik Tok maintenant il a fait une partie
entre rezane avec je sais même plus
combien maintenant de vues j'ai perdu le
compte
en tout cas on a une belle communauté
française qui commence un petit peu à se
développer là dans le stream c'est hyper
cool
alors C3 donc n'a qu'à qui souhaitent
toujours un petit peu
les fixé il est fixé c'est dur de jouer
mais attention par Aviane au temps par
moment dans les certaines positions il
est vraiment plus lent que Naka ce qui
est normal mais il faut qu'il garde une
réserve de temps sinon il sera il sera
avoir dans le monétime c'est dur comme
décision ce qui vient de faire n'a qu'à
donner la case G5
aussi c'est très très dur mais bon
il pense qu'il va pouvoir faire ça et
qu'il aura quand même accès à toi
bon appétit à toi
à bientôt Serge
avec plaisir pas de
petite pizza ananas de thé vert elle
était pas mal celle-là
ok petit pressing de bout en bout mais
comment on va faire plier les Noirs ici
et puis si on trouve pas de solution on
peut vite perdre du temps et la perdre
autant d'accord en plus il joue vite il
y a une position où il aimerait bien
mais il joue vite il met la pression et
il voit tout
et du coup qu'est-ce qu'on fait
maintenant
c'est pas forcément idéal on a un peu
émoussé tout ce qui vient de se passer
donc du coup là au meilleur moment on
accueille il sort un peu du bois
jamais goûté mais juste le fait de voir
ça
j'ai après juste beaucoup tu vois parce
que j'ai pas goûté mais
la moyenne
[Musique]
bizarre quoi ah bah là on a plus le
choix le stream qui usine bah ouais le
match est une boucherie donc on se
prépare ce que l'autre jour j'ai vu
alors j'étais avec ma copine et
elle a mangé une glace mon compte manger
des frites et elle a pris une frite et
elle a trempé dans ma glace
pas les frites et
la glace
dans mon pays c'est normal il y a même
au McDo des menus frites glaces j'ai dit
mais c'est une blague
bon ça y est ça commence à complètement
déconner vous voyez pourquoi faut pas
être en direct contre Naka
et à chaque coup il joue vite il met la
pression pas forcément le plus précis
mais des coûts qui gardent la pression
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps
contre une minute 30 on peut pas jouer
comme ça ça va être rapide avant il a
pas été du coup hop à chaque fois même
si jamais tu arrives à la haute play ils
font encore de finir et c'est encore une
autre histoire
et vous pouvez pas c'est trop tard ça va
être la fin de cette partie
très très bientôt
j'ai peut-être tout à deux qui est pas
morte
ça fait du coup maintenant 5 et demi
dur dur
5 et demi à
demi et maintenant qui joue Beckham
Nakamura
en fait l'ordi aime bien avec les noirs
seulement sur le long terme les blancs
ils arrivent souvent à récupérer des
du jeu au centre et c'est pas si facile
que cela en fait
parce qu'on a une majorité centrale
potentielle avec plus de pions ensemble
du coup c'est pas c'est pas si facile en
vrai
c'est c'est ouf pour l'avoir
[Musique]
truc il est il est juste trop fort et du
coup dans les ouvertures très très bon
en règle générale il y en a une où il a
fait un concept un peu un peu délégueux
mais sinon il arrive à bien s'en sortir
il faut dire que Naka joue des choses
même avec les Blancs un peu bizarroïdes
[Musique]
notre tour 8 se trouvant en rayon laser
de la date qui fait que ça
ça fait mal direct je viens d'avoir
[Musique]
l'idée est bonne mais il pouvait faire
aussi fou prendre de d'abord parce que
là il y a peut-être F3 F3 non il y aura
peut-être pris C3 en tout cas c'est
l'idée sympa ouvrir les cases noires
parce que je suis le seul à voir les
cases noires ça a montré dans tous les
écoles
et la question c'est est-ce qu'on
pouvait pas faire [ __ ] en deux et ce
même coup bon c'était c'était une autre
histoire
mais en tout cas
Nakamura n'est pas content il a fait la
mine du mec un peu de Dax qui vient de
faire des Français 5 il se prend des
cartes comme dans les livres il y a
menace de Détroit il y a des histoires
de dépenser 3 prise de trois voilà ya F3
c'est pour ça que je me demande c'était
le seul coup je crois si on pouvait pas
faire [ __ ] Decathlon idée et
ça aurait pu faire mal
donc il a râlé mais maintenant il faut
qu'il trouve je pense que le coup c'est
peut-être pris ces trois ici
pris ces trois pour garder le pressing
il y a d'autres coups on peut jouer des
coups beaucoup plus romantiques comme
tout reprendre 3 suivi de prise C3 que
je sais pas si l'adversaire peut oui
j'aime bien l'idée tout reprend un 3
prise G4 prise C3
mais c'est très compliqué à évaluer
parce qu'il y a des tours F6 il y a
beaucoup de coups non tout problème si
ça marche pas bien et dans des 8 mais
j'ai l'impression qu'on a du jeu tout
reprend les trois rigolo c'est tout ici
et on a un jeu de folie
il y a plein de possibilités on a
l'impression
mais encore une fois c'est pas ravial de
prendre cette décision et c'est ça qui
est souvent dedans en fait quand vous
avez beaucoup de possibilités comme ça
c'est le moment des fois où on craque
parce que on sait même plus quoi faire
tellement on est bien quoi complètement
prise c'est deux ça a l'air pas mal
c'est pas mal aussi
parce qu'après ces trois c'est cavaliers
B prend ses trois qui me gênait
mais bon ok c'est peut-être bien avec
et
même tout simplement faut acheter parce
que tu prends tu fais eux prendre des 4
peut-être je te reprends au dodo d'en
prendre deux car il faudrait
un coup un peu dans ton style
mais là du coup
ce qui veut probablement c'est fou c'est
c'est pas mal joué quand même j'avais
pas eu cette idée il a pris du temps
mais il est à 2,50 il est pas ridicule
et il pose un problème je suis pas sûr
que enfin il y avait tellement de coups
candidats dans la position que il n'est
pas certain que
tout prévu ni regarder faut aussi donc
là ça m'intéresse grosse partie là de
parvient bon faut dire que c'est B4
premier coup donc ça donne un petit peu
le petit plus à l'adversaire
en tout cas là vous voyez à prise
foussée 4 et après ça laisse beaucoup de
motif de fou prendre deux cahier prend
des quatre ok ok prends des cartes
jouets
on peut insérer le petit fouet 4
on garde le pressing là il y aura
sûrement B prend celle 6 comme ça on
garde
la pression
tour apprend des 8 pour avoir tout
reprend E3 et peut-être ici ce qu'on a
tour des trois tours
comment on continue
extrêmement fort en défense tu vois il a
deux pions de moins de plus mais
mais il est vraiment sous pression au
niveau du au niveau de ce que le petit
coup ouais j'ai regardé ça aussi Cavalia
3 mais la pression donc la foudre et
j'ai le motif ou prend C5 il va ajouter
deux perdre trois mais rétablir un petit
peu la
l'égalité à nouveau tout dans cette
partie c'est une possibilité
c'est pas si mal
parce qu'il était sous pression
de prendre le demi-point pour pas se
cagouler alors que c'est bien égalisant
moi sa place j'aurais demandé de et on
fait vraiment
[Musique]
nullementer à cause du temps
je pense pas que ça joue
si tu penses à jour
il y a pas de raison pour l'instant
comme le mec a un peu cagoulé il va
essayer de l'embêter quoi
bon là ça commence à être de plus en
plus d'être drôle comme on dit c'est à
dire vraiment une nulle facile pour
n'importe qui
il n'y a pas beaucoup de petites idées
comment ça il a refusignan comment
est-ce qu'il compte la pression
mais l'énerver un petit peu il aime bien
il aime bien ce côté-là puis bon il est
sur ce sur ce pan là c'est ce qui excite
un petit peu le côté internet on va dire
voilà il en profite pour pour
s'alimenter comme les grands sportifs
la sortie la petite gourde de thé
et là maintenant il y a très peu de
motifs mais il attend presque voilà
comment ça se passe
c'est pas trop de passer
le seul passage c'est par il a aucun
passage
hello pendrix bon il a
voilà il se prend pas trop la traite par
aviani je reste simple ça y est ils sont
égalité autant
bon c'est bien pour parabian c'est une
nul beaucoup plus
[Musique]
beaucoup plus acceptable que la première
où il était archi gagnant
donc le temps passe quand même il reste
17 minutes ça va faire nul et du coup il
restera plus beaucoup de temps dans ce
premier set et du coup maintenant par
rapport à votre pari par un a plus le
droit de prendre une
tout à fait tout à fait
Paris il va rester une ou deux parties
je pense deux
oui normalement c'est deux ça dépend ça
dépend de combien de temps ça dure
[Musique]
contre
c'est terminé avec une victoire de
Sceaux avec deux points d'écart
d'ailleurs qui a qui m'arrange bien
et du coup là on est sur Nakamura par
avion
il veut peut-être faire toutes les cases
possibles avec son fou
donc demain on aura demain on aura
d'ailleurs le match c'est prévu Sarine
contre dingly Rennes le premier quart de
finale demain je peux pas encore vous
dire à quelle heure je vous le dirai en
quelques minutes on n'a pas encore les
nouvelles
donc c'est vraiment joué pour jouer
mais bon on savait que ça allait pas
être facile on savait à quoi s'attendre
parce que là il y a vraiment rien donc
il continue jupe pour juste pour rien
18 victoires contre trois défaites et
cette nuit pendant que non je pense pas
moi je pense qu'il y aura beaucoup
différents
à peu près au 140e coups un petit peu
avant peut-être 136 137 ça fera nulle et
pendant ce temps là et ben Nakamura va
eu le nerf son adversaire et en plus et
ben le temps c'est cool donc il y aura
je pense encore une fois peut-être deux
parties qui restent normalement
une c'est ça peut être aussi une
14 minutes une partie largement je pense
la tête de Parian m'a bien fait marrette
15h ouais je pense c'est dans le dans le
but de
je pense qu'il a deux idées je pense que
il en a marre
il va peut-être passer dans du 3 + 1 du
coup il fait passer le temps parce qu'on
a marre juste
et
en plus il veut aussi tirer son
adversaire il joue depuis le début il
joue depuis le début il joue du A3 H3 B4
dans les ouvertures et il veut juste
l'utilité donc
voilà là on arrive au 124e coup encore
10 coups je pense à peu près
merci beaucoup bip bip merci beaucoup à
18 victoires cette nulles et trois
défaites
en train de regarder le spectacle
aujourd'hui ton pronostic merci beaucoup
pour ces infos bip bip
er
cette nul cette partie aura duré quand
même 5 minutes de plus
il aura tourné pendant 5 minutes parce
que j'avais dit tout à l'heure il avait
dit 17 minutes
[Musique]
il y a de bonne chance ça m'arrange un
petit peu Kevin d'entre nous
oui oui oui bien sûr on dirait qu'il a
fait ça exprès
je lui ai dit
et 129 nul
mais on aura quand même sans doute de
partir on verra mais ah non c'est pas
sûr que Marc
ça dépend ça dépend de ce que nous fait
par Aviane entre
donc 6 1 donc je vous rappelle que par
rapport à ce 7 j'ai parié que Arabian ne
dépasserait pas les 1 points dans ce set
et Kevin apparaît sur un et demi donc du
coup si une réponse à ce gain avec la
tour de plus quoi à tout mais c'est la
totale quoi
pas mal de réussite
et du coup c'est le format qui est
ridicule où le format bah il a fait
progresser contre mais en vrai blue moi
je pense que sûrement il est pas mal
quand les quand les le niveau sont
équivalents au final
après il pourrait il pourrait durer
moins longtemps sur parce que il les
font jouer longtemps quoi mais c'est bon
au format et que pour ça c'est pour
cette raison aussi qui qui fait ce qu'il
a fait aujourd'hui pour montrer à quel
point bah ça l'a fait filté quoi mais
après on a 14 ans c'est un joueur qui
joue et puis il aime bien oui stream
c'est un peu un show pour lui quoi donc
du coup bah il fait ça et jusqu'à la fin
et voilà quoi après bon on dira tout ce
qu'on voudra c'est pas classe quoi voilà
non évidemment c'est pas classe ça c'est
clair et net
qui peut presque gagner le fou si il
bouge pas alors que les gens pourraient
faire cavaler prendre un point et à
trois ou quatre donc là il a obligé un
paraguern dans les ouvertures sur s'il y
a quand même une petite masterclass de
parabia dans ce match qu'il perd quand
même relativement facilement c'est qu'il
démonte toutes les petites ouvertures de
Nakamura comment il fait il prend des
bons avantages et ils montent des
systèmes donc ce match il a un intérêt
pédagogique pour les pour les joueurs
amateurs qui voudraient revenir sur les
parties parce qu'il y a des bonnes
choses qui ont été montrées quand même à
chaque fois il est proche d'un pion
d'avance dans l'ouverture mais bon ok ça
glait blanc et ça compte des ouvertures
marginales mais il propose quelque chose
et d'ailleurs à chaque fois il y a
souvent l'échange d'infos contre un
cavalier après je joue sur la couleur
peut-être X à 3 dans cette position on
peut aller aussi vers G5 on verra mais
en tout cas
il fait des choses il propose
après la camoureuse
tout à fait
donc bon
il essaie de troll un peu l'adversaire
et l'énerver je pense surtout ça qu'il
essaie de faire depuis le début du match
il y a eu des bonnes entreprendre X et
Mister Pesoa c'était quand même très
très beau entre la chemise et le décor
Roland-Garros de Naka ça c'était bon ça
c'est toujours comme ça il a très
souvent ce type de chemise et truc un
peu à wagen etc vous voyez d'ailleurs il
avait des ananas c'est chorizo je pense
l'ananas
je pense qu'il a il a enlevé la masse de
la pizza il a posé sur le mur
[Musique]
mais le banc là où tu vas l'avoir non
mais la banque là que tu vas l'avoir
mais pas en 5 minutes tu vas voir une
Bullet en Bullet tu vas en avoir plein
je pense parce qu'en plus le score
risque d'être élevé c'est quoi dommage 4
ça fait un peu
non
sublime sublime
voilà
et oui
nickel ça
c'est pas mal en plus c'est superbe
bravo
bravo David beau mental tu peux tu peux
rajouter tu peux rajouter
ça c'est bien ça
tu peux rajouter le plus de
crash
on a fait des Paris entre nous et du
coup ben ça y est il passait à deux donc
là j'ai perdu le premier pari
mais tu méritais parce que il y a quand
même une partie qui aurait dû gagner
qu'il a fait et dans le fond ben tu
mérites quoi
je dirais pas ça dans le match d'avant
maintenant
instantanément au moment où j'ai gagné
heureusement heureusement que j'ai gagné
les deux subs là-dessus parce
instantanément j'ai reçu un sms de ma
conjointe tu vois qui est dans le salon
qui me demande de lui faire un virement
tu vois
je sais pas si c'est en lien avec les
soeurs peut-être qu'elle est devant le
stream tu vois en prévision de ce mois
de décembre voilà de ce mois de cadeau
voilà voilà comment ça se passe tout dès
que dès que déjà que j'en gagne pas
beaucoup des subs mais direct on me
demande un virement dès que je gagne
deux seuls quoi tu vois c'est la vie est
dure en ce moment franchement
et là encore Naka il commence à jouer
des ouvertures
très très chaud parce que là il a fait
H3 mais tout à l'heure c'était
relativement sérieux derrière parce
qu'il transposait
dans des anglaises dans des débuts
référencés alors là il a plutôt
il est allé vers une robe et là sa
position est toute trouée de partout
avec un tf4 et le cavalier noir c'est 5
qui peut revenir en E6 en tout cas c'est
c'est assez moche
qui fait il y a plein de trous sur place
noir en plus pour la carte je pensais
pas que ça allait finir comme ça ce 7
allez allez on continue mon petit
mon petit David on prend les points
parce que là c'est très bien il faut
qu'il marque un max de points attends
excuse-moi on avait dit quoi on avait
dit le plus proche d'accord
si David s'envole tu seras content et là
c'est pas mal là je suis déjà j'ai un
petit sourire parce que
je trouvais que moralement c'était dur
et là je me dis que pour son moral c'est
hyper bien quoi ouais mais en fait je
pense que je suis pas mal non
en fait je pense que j'ai moyen de me
faire
en fait attends il y a il y a une partie
je pensais que j'allais me prendre 10-0
tu vois parce que je me suis dit ça va
être la totale même en plus un la parade
va faire un petit sursaut d'orgueil tu
sais mais
là maintenant je suis un peu plus
confiant mais on sait qu'au speech dès
qu'on est confiant à Paris sauf ça
déconne donc du coup j'ai pas j'ai pas
faire le mariole j'ai vu pour l'instant
ma bankroll de ce speech en terme de
Paris j'ai pas pouvoir te dire que tout
va bien dans le meilleur des mondes
après le 9 à 5 gland de de l'après-midi
à deux points et qu'il a exactement
quatre victoires
et qui disent
on a fait le match Bressac térieux et je
peux te dire qu'on a fait format
speechess heureusement donc Stéphane il
m'a battu dans tous les trucs à chaque
fois d'un poil il a été il m'a fidélisé
quoi il m'a fait croire que j'allais
revenir et à chaque fois c'était des sur
la petite plus petite démarche et
heureusement qu'on avait rajouté une
manche en tactique où j'ai pu ouais j'ai
pu sauver l'honneur on va dire
heureusement parce que et c'était à
l'époque où les paris se passaient
beaucoup mieux avec souffle voilà un peu
vengé on avait pas fait exactement
pareil on avait fait un format un peu
pareil avec plusieurs cadences
différentes non mais on l'avait fait par
par 7 et on n'est pas du tout joué
pendant une heure ni rien on a vu il
fait des scènes de trois non le premier
on le premier en 3 je crois dans chaque
ou je peux en 5 qu'on avait fait j'ai
mené plusieurs fois deux et demi genre
deux et demi un demi et Pam la patatras
ou deux un et
je suis bien fait fidéliser vos
souvenirs il y aura une revanche on
s'est dit ça mais on a on a du mal à
trouver du temps en fait parce qu'on a
un petit peu partout d'ailleurs on
voulait faire une revanche cette fois-ci
on voulait la jouer en tchesse 960 et
éventuellement mettre trois cadences et
se terminant en Bullet en random chess
ça peut vraiment être drôle bon ça je
pense qu'en Bullet j'ai bien bien morflé
avec avec Stéphane parce que je suis pas
grand spécialiste mais pour autant le
random le fait commenter le random de
chasse avec avec Stéphane on avait
vraiment bien rigolé et
apprécier en fait le randoms qui est
pour nous bah ouais culturellement n'en
fait déjà on en fait jamais et on
n'avait pas mal déliré à commenter cela
on avait trouvé que les mecs avaient des
idées hyper créatives ils avaient le
droit de se préparer un quart d'heure
pour la nouvelle position qui
apparaissait vous rappelez de chasse 960
on inverse toutes les pièces
sur la première rangée on donne la même
position noire en symétrie et on y va
donc il y a pas de théorie il y a juste
des principes d'ouverture à respecter et
on s'était régalé franchement
particulièrement la partie c'était
naka-45 d'ailleurs qui était super
génial qui a commencé par le premier
coup de Carlson un sacrifice de pièces
au premier vignoble c'était
[Musique]
le X qui pouvait croquer la tour à 8 non
la dame pardon stuff et qui pourrait se
faire enfermer
danseur dans cette partie ouais c'est
dommage parce que c'est pas c'est pas
comme ça qui va
qui va améliorer
donc là on peut se passer qui a bougé la
tour sûrement un j'étais en train de
regarder les cavaliers.fr
mais on peut simplement effectivement
bouger la tour parce que il doit
regarder aussi un Akara cavalier.f4 puis
on prend F4
dans ma F4 fois H3 dame 5 échec mais
c'est ça pas l'air suffisant
donc elle est tout rachat tout rachat
pour revenir sur la colonne des
oui en tout cas victoire un peu tombé du
ciel pour pour parabian
du tout ça
c'est vraiment un gros point assez cher
parce que ça relance le mec qui est plus
qui a une victoire au compteur après
faut pas qu'il se relâche non plus parce
que là
c'est un peu le cas
je pense
il a posé le petit problème mais la
preuve du Fou d'essai donc
il va être obligé de jouer un coup comme
style fou aussi c'est après il y a le
problème du bon il a pas joué parce
qu'il y avait F4 en fait donc il était
obligé de jouer grand rock je crois
mais c'est pas le coup qu'on a vraiment
envie de jouer dans ces positions
le petit pion 5 et
c'est pas simple pour les Noirs il reste
30 secondes pour ce temps réglementaire
en haut de la dernière partie c'est la
dernière ou de soulagement
sur ce don en fait parce qu'il y a eu
don alors il y avait eu le premier don
qui était à l'initiative de quand même
tout à l'heure par là il a fait nul une
position mais vraiment que tout le monde
gagnait
et là dont les carreaux à la surprise
générale parce qu'il était vraiment
maître de ce qui faisait depuis le
départ même si c'est ouvertures sont ce
qu'elles sont il faut bien reconnaître
qu'après il est tellement malin
tellement fort tout simplement tellement
tellement rapide que il était en train
de la coller très sévèrement à part
Aviane et il a laissé une tactique de
assez basique derrière il y a dame 7 qui
va commencer à peut-être poser problème
comment on va faire ça même peut-être
qu'on peut croquer tout simplement les
pions
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on fait un petit dame 7 pour
moi
parce que s'il faut F7 cavalier cavalier
C5 c'est chaud et si tout revu je peux
prendre Hachette maintenant stuff ok je
pensais qu'il allait intercalé d'un
mecset j'ai pas vu pourquoi pourquoi on
faisait pas un petit dame 7 comme les
ordis d'abord
bon en tout cas c'est gagnant maintenant
ça on a une mine d'avance au temps et on
a un pion qui avance tout seul
parvient de tente le tout pour le tout
avec une pseudo-attaque à l'aile
très sévèrement
de C4 peut-être pour pour aller jusqu'au
bout de la bêtise
il faut tenter quelque chose la pâte en
TC4
du coup le cavalier il est surtout il a
une minute quand on connaît sa qualité
très très dur très très dur pour
pour notre ami prise comme élève 3
contre les échecs
[Musique]
plein de petites attaques plein de
petites fourberies on aura bon coin
[Musique]
et là c'est fini il y a deux pions de
plus une seconde à la pendule et ça va
être terminé ado tourin puis on pousse
les pions et puis
tu viens de déconner à la partie d'avant
donc il a pas envie de de se faire
fidéliser prise d'un F5 H7 peut-être
qu'on peut faire achat directement
et là il y a pas de chèque non plus
chaque roi là
il y avait un DA machin très classe tout
pour évidemment
c'est marrant
je pensais qu'il allait le faire eh il a
fait tu vois il a fini par le faire
du coup
en 5 + 1 qui sont une par 7 2 pour Naka
du prédominant très dominant il est à il
est à la cool heureusement il lui en a
laissé une donc parvient de peu se
refaire en 3 + 1 j'espère qu'il va
réussir à en emporter deux pour faire un
petit demi là dans la phase de 1 + 1 on
va voir
[Musique]
on va voir
l'idéal mais bon une heure quand même
beaucoup de ça
va être dur bon tu crois qu'on fait un
petit pause ok
minutes pour pour le début du 3 + 1 donc
exactement à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on est de retour et oui à glace
scandinave ni caroustouf ça change
encore
ah oui c'est normal c'est normal c'est
normal c'est normal
j'étais sur la bonne mais j'avais tout
changé parce que j'avais fait les choses
pendant la pause et du coup j'ai plus
les caméras parce que j'avais j'avais
fait des choses bref on est de retour
[Musique]
pour tes Paris tu as l'air bien meilleur
que nous
je l'ai pas oublié pour une fois
c'est au top une heure de trois plus une
heure pour que par avion mette de la
presse
et s'adapte aux ouvertures assez
fantasques de son adversaire à cette
cadence ultra rapide
tout de suite le fou G6 il attend il a
le temps pour le faire peut-être F4 à un
moment pour lui faire des F5 après des
pions des pions moches voilà c'est joué
c'est assez logique
F5 est joué maintenant est-ce que
vraiment on va donner le cavalier c'est
pas sûr par contre on aimerait bien le
garder au final
j'aime pas trop
là j'ai trois ça va être joué vite fait
déjà sorti peut-être de
sa poésie petite menace de foi 5 pour
faire revivre le fou alors est-ce qu'on
y va maintenant
il va le jouer hein
il est pas très content de lui
parler il a oublié X5 je crois je l'ai
vu je l'ai vu un petit
et c'est pas très logique de jouer tout
pour enfermer le fouet de le laisser
s'échapper
et là maintenant tous les pièces de d'un
coup du carreaux sont mis en marche et
là je peux vous dire que
il aura d'autres essais mais ça part pas
très bien déjà
honnêtement
il a déjà 30 secondes de moins 40
secondes OK et il avait toutes ces
pièces actives maintenant elles sont
toutes inactives c'est complètement
trompé
bon ça a commencé à déconner quand j'ai
proposé F4 et qu'il l'a fait mais bon ça
c'est une autre histoire
aïe aïe aïe aïe
et maintenant pression incroyable que
c'est faux enfermé en G6 se retrouve en
H5 à nous mettre la pression quoi c'est
terrible
on peut être vraiment
l'accuse le coup un petit peu parvient
parce que ça va vite alors il y a
l'histoire de qu'il doit rester en vie
au temps et attention là il y a des
dames 4 dames 4 échec qui sont
comment il fait sur
peut-être cavalier E5
ouais je sais pas comment on fait sur
damocat et chaque donc on
on joue quoi
tout va me casser chaque qu'est-ce qu'on
joue pour sauver la position
d'enfant F prend et tout reprend des 8
in extremis
bon c'est clair
mais bon on a pas une belle position
avec
[Musique]
les blancs tout à l'heure il avait une
position en or qui sait qu'il a bien
gâché
mais là je pense que tu vois
autant en 5 + une il a réussi quand même
à prendre des points à Dakar autant en
trois plus filmes ça va quand même
beaucoup plus vite et
je pense que ça va être plus dur encore
pour par avion qui qui est en période de
doute
et qui
n'arrive pas toujours à transformer
donc je pense que ça avance plus ça
j'aime pas trop
les pièces sont connectés
deux stuff s'il va y avoir des systèmes
comme ça pour l'instant il y a le foot
c'est 5 en l'air encore peut-être faire
un petit B5 aussi par moment
je pensais aussi à un coup comme tour
reprend il faut prendre un cavalier F2
qui était là
ce qui est bien c'est que pour une fois
réfléchir un incap parce qu'il y a
vraiment beaucoup de possibilités
tactiques après un accueille il est
possible qu'il trouve quelque chose de
concret B5 c'est le coup je voulais
jouer très simple d'un point d'homme
tourpont-eau 4
oui mais tu perds
[Musique]
puis on prend pour prendre pour prendre
Fouin et avec puis on prend une pièce à
la fin
c'est d'en prendre un puis on prend ton
contour ton contour et bouger le
cavalier alors tout reprend des 8 mais
un problème là on arrive pas à le régler
comment on va régler le problème sauf
parce que
on avait un peu la même genre
il y a plus le il y a plus le fou c'est
5 en l'air il y a plus les clouages et
ça y est par Aviane va faire des
longueurs et tu manges juste avant tu
manges là quoi
mais bon qu'est-ce que ça change
[Musique]
direct voilà
continue à faire
un petit peu à droite j'ai l'impression
que c'est comme si peut-être que naquage
son écran il a mis la tête de parrain
Vienne pour voir un peu ses réactions
c'est possible je sais pas si on a le
droit je pense que je pense que oui
et du coup le fait de voir par arriver
un petit thé ça peut motiver en fait
vous voyez
le conforté dans le fait que il n'a pas
trop envie d'abandonner le genre de
position mais bon c'est un peu
obligatoire quoi allez du coup 1-0 dans
ce deuxième scène
[Musique]
il a révisé peut-être une petite fiche
contre B3
qui se transforme en pseudo anglaise et
on y va
il joue le caméléon G6 c'est un peu
bizarre non dans l'anglaise d'ailleurs
il s'est pris le thématique H4
après on voit que la barque quand même
descend bien en bas oui tout à fait
après on voit la belle case D4 laisser
souffle c'est vrai que le fait de faire
H4 quand tu mets ton cavalier en F3
après
il a compris pas mal de choses parce que
il peut jouer des 6 ou G4
cavalier aussi ce qui a validé 4 en fait
il allait venir directement là et ça
c'est assez profond et c'est très bien
joué de la part de par avion
il est pas content
il a pas compris en fait je pense
[Musique]
un excellent jour d'échec mais c'est
juste que entre les deux est énorme mais
c'est pour ça que
en partie lente ça serait une autre
histoire par avion il aurait le temps
alors ça hikao serait normalement
dominateur sur le papier
mais en partie ultra rapide là s'il y a
des réflexes de folie qu'il faut avoir
il en a des réflexes de folie par
ailleurs mais pas assez par un top
player comme comme carreau tout
simplement
passer par le côté F5 on sait qu'il
mettrait l'autre mais il veut pas
échanger le faux C8 pour le moment OK
8 et la Casa F3 quand même en intermetzo
peut-être c'est rigolo
F3 d'adulte
et on ferme la dame petit moment de
solitude pour la team révolution échec
là
alors on menace une sorte de maths du
berger là on va essayer de faire des
petites choses peut-être des petits
câlins F2
bon en tout cas il s'est fait gruger une
minute déjà d'accord donc une chance
pour paravian
faut y aller c'est le genre de
partie ou
ça se prend
et David maintenant
par rapport à Paris ça m'arrangerait pas
que même il arrive à un dans ce 7
qu'on peut pas faire une un petit coup
de magicien
que tu vas cliquer sur la colonne
maintenant qu'on lui a provoqué ça
comment on fait parce que ça reste quand
même un petit peu
embêtant ce qu'on ramène le cavalier en
D4
mais je prends rendez-vous tout le temps
non j'ai l'impression que ma position
elle est pas si mauvaise une fois qu'on
échange tout ouais
en tout cas il joue vite et très souvent
en fait quand on a quatre très souvent
il a des poubelles un petit peu et il
joue en fait extrêmement vite et il met
le doute et ses positions sont mauvaises
mais jamais simples à un moment
convertir et du coup il met le doute et
il te met la pression là je sais pas
d'ailleurs comment
mais tu sens que tu es mieux que tu sais
tu sens que tu es mieux mais
si on met une tour en F1 je commence à
avoir peur ouais voilà bah il a mis
parce que j'ai la jauge je me dis ok
d'accord c'est sans doute mieux mais en
pratique je trouve que c'est compliqué
extrêmement dur
que je sais pas quel coup jouer là dans
cette position ah oui on laisse prendre
le 5
ok dame j'ai 5 il est en train de sortir
une énorme partie par Aviane
et là on peut peut-être est-ce qu'on
peut reprendre E5 à Tours F5 quand même
il y a la case G4 pour la dame
carreaux et en difficulté il le sent
salut
trop bonjour à toi
alors alors
allez par avion là il faut décoincer là
il joue super bien mais super lentement
là dans la phase critique en même temps
c'est chaud on peut comprendre qui je
crois tout franchement moi j'arrive pas
à comprendre ce qui se passe dans cette
position j'arrive on peut jouer
peut-être on y va on joue on joue aux
échecs on prend E5 tout F5 dame Jerry 4
tours 5 jouer sur le fait que le roi
blanc est de toute façon
le roi blanc est mal placé et que il va
jouer au centre avec tout 8 tourbé 8
essayez d'aller chercher le roi blanc
non mais là très bien joué par Avène le
problème c'est qu'il a été trop lent
donc maintenant il se retrouve avec sa
seconde c'est n'importe quoi sa gestion
du temps elle a été mauvaise dans le
moment critique parce que là il a une
très bonne position il a fait une jolie
partie
il faut que je vais te la par contre là
pour maca
je pense qu'il sent qu'il est pas très
bien d'accord
donc si ça se retourne tant pis pour lui
très très peu de temps
[Musique]
c'est vraiment dur comme les deux
il y a plus de temps
la pression jusqu'au bout il y a fuite
qui peut arriver
à tout moment te reprends des trois
c'est le craquage avec la Fourchette qui
arrive ici si manger la tour
incroyable Naka
dans cette technique
très chaud c'est mieux pour les Noirs
maintenant c'est plus facile en plus il
a un peu cracouiller
je pense que ça va être parti gagner
pour par avion dommage maca qui avait
réussi à
revenir dans cette partie
il faut manger il faut tenir cette
position c'est un bonbon direct parce
que ton collègue bien David bravo
bonjour Bullet David franchement
impressionnant
que je vais perdre tous mes matchs
c'est pas sûr parce que là tu m'as collé
neuf hein je suis pas sûr d'en dire
autant la fin de ce match là j'ai un
petit un petit sursaut qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce A5 là
on voulait faire non mais c'est premier
coup il a joué à E40 j'ai pas eu le
temps de voir tu vois
en train d'essayer de te regarder pour
voir tes réactions après cette cette
défaite tu vois
et c'est le problème en fait c'est qu'il
est il est il est quitté quoi et c'est
énorme et c'est ce qui fait que en fait
au final je risque de pas me parler
il a pas vu une fois au carré x 5 qui
joue que des trucs
de le max de Seb David
mais bon la connaît hein David serait
capable de gagner cette partie là et
après de plus marquer un produit match
et on la connaît celle-là
même si ça ne va pas tu vois parce que
bon il finirait à 4 ce qui me ferait
gagner le total tu vois déjà ce gagne au
total là ok mais bon je perds partout
parce que s'il y a de partout tu fais
encore gagnant 1 + 1 au final cavalier
G6
des fougères il y a quand même des gens
des petits choses il y a encore le
cavalier des cartes pour l'instant
madame des trois rois F7 on les connaît
ses positions là elles sont pas Gégé
quand même
il va jouer avec aussi plutôt calmement
d'avis de te laisse pas en bobiner par
la petite chiotte qu'il est en train de
te faire ouh là ok pourquoi pas
par avion quand même
pas mal quand même
il se débrouille très bien même il se
débrouille très bien je pense après
après il faut bien dire après celle-ci
donna kamura mais bon il lui joue au
kata 5 il lui joue que des ouvertures de
daube donc il est quand même assez ça
peut être interprété soit chaud soyez
respectueux c'est pas c'est pas le sujet
mais en tout cas il joue pas ses
meilleures échecs il se met pas en
condition il est à bloc par Aviane il y
a 8 3 c'est pour ça aussi qui qui fait
ça on a Nakamura ils sont vraiment pas
en danger et il y a quand même plus 5
alors qu'ils jouent des ouvertures il
tire une balle dans le pied dans les
débuts quoi
donc mais on peut pas dire que c'est le
vrai écart pour l'instant
en tout cas c'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
il est assez créé en plus j'ai
l'impression quand même
bon c'est position il faut faire
extrêmement gaffe parce que mine de rien
le kfc4 tout ça
il peut y avoir des sacrifices sura-3
qui peut arriver même Tham à 5 avec p5b4
mais la structure que moi aussi chez les
Blancs elle est un peu elle a un peu
dangereuse tu vois
est-ce qu'en fait on rage 3 pour pour
assurer le coup déjà intéressant
et peut-être c'est 3 kb4 ça existe des
fois
se prendre une une carotte des 5 C34
secondes quand même pour parabian ok il
a il a bien joué mais il a joué trop
lentement pour moi alors c'est facile à
dire
mangeant ces quatre
sans doute entre les deux mais bon
ça donne pas forcément envie mais roi il
met du temps pour jouer les coups 10
secondes encore ça va commencer à
compter mais il a eu peur peut-être de
caler prend à droite prise à trois tours
C2 ouais voilà et ça c'est chaud
maintenant avec plus de temps mais de
toute façon on est obligé de prendre
pour ces deux c'est super chaud à
défendre tu peux tomber un jour il faut
trouver le bon coup de défense et c'est
quoi le bon coup de défense j'en sais
rien
il y a beaucoup de jeux juste dame de 4
MP3 encore plus fort
bah oui mais faut pas s'étonner là
honnêtement au niveau il a fait une très
bonne partie mais il s'est mis tellement
mal au temps que c'est plus une bonne
partie que c'est la défaite
au moins il a appris on sait que c'est
horrible
tout le temps il est
à 4 c'est reparti
un joueur qui fait défonce et qui joue à
4 qui te respecte pas alors qu'en plus
en plus sur
tu es quand même top top joueur quoi tu
vois c'est c'est assez mignon ce genre
de choses
[Musique]
cinéma comme si vous voulez se rappeler
d'une variante alors que la joue A4 s'il
te plaît quoi tu viens de jouer à 4 et
tu veux te rappeler de nous
c'est toujours moins bien mais
après avoir joué X à deux quoi ils
peuvent vraiment te jouer des coups peu
naturels pas très esthétiques très très
vite
manger le fou
en tout cas
il veut faire tilter par Aviane
par exemple faut qu'il joue voilà les
petits coups de pression rapide mais pas
exagéré et faut sortir le
qui c'est un petit cadet
on joue simple et vite dans ces 7
pourquoi pas
je très vite ces trois tu as vu la
vitesse du C3 sur dame C7 qui attaque
ton cheval
comme prévu en fait normalement pomme il
joue ces trois
en fait il te met trop la pression les
trois un peu fou si tu veux quoi il
prend bien sûr bien sûr
[Musique]
des coups qui sont logiques ils jouent
son jeu quoi et trois il y a des fois F4
il aurait mieux fait de sortir son
cavalier plutôt et maintenant il faut F4
c'est les blancs qui ont un petit
pressing qui est sorti nulle part et en
plus on a du mal à se bulle cavalier
parce que on apprend au 7 qui arrive
donc là c'est vraiment
un endroit très en forme très incisif
qui prend pas beaucoup de temps pour
pour embêter par avion
là j'ai l'impression que cette partie
elle va faire mal
quand il est mieux
et tu vois et il a il se la jouer un peu
quoi non mais carrément il va raconte
grave mais honnêtement
et de par moment et Caro c'est quand il
dessert un petit peu qu'il est le moins
précis quand il joue hyper naturel hyper
vite tout ça il est hyper fort c'est ouf
il est hyper dangereux mais c'est quand
il réfléchit
qu'il est en fait le moins bon je pense
dans ce match en tout cas c'est ça dès
qu'il a envie de trop bien faire il faut
qu'il joue un peu sale
ouais je sais pas je sais pas si à ce
point-là non mais ok ça pété ça reste un
truc mais en fait bon c'est
un personnage
oui voilà juste en fait il joue un rôle
un petit peu tu vois
attention menace il est parti il a
enlevé la menace
être cavalier
pour sortir de du vis-à-vis et après
bouger la dame
fois H5 ok
un peu bizarre sur deux coups
à 5
c'est sûrement pas mal
[Musique]
en plus en plus il fait-il parce que il
joue il joue A4 au premier coup à 5 avec
les Noirs il joue tout pour faire t-il
par avion et te dire je peux pas
entendre quoi et du coup pour le moment
si on se fait distancer on voit que mais
c'est pas facile mais pas qu'il cherche
de trop il va te foutu là ils étaient il
était à égalité au time longtemps
un truc un peu normal mais c'est pas
facile alors
il est pas ridicule dans les parties
ultra rapide donc ça c'est bien quand
même pour tenir le choc c'est pour ça
aussi qui se qualifié en gros c'est
un mot qui utilisait beaucoup au poker
qui veut dire en fait bah juste bah tu
ris quoi tu tu je sais pas comment
expliquer
à l'époque il y avait le flipper qui
tiltait voilà ça c'est il y a une
référence plus ancienne ok
quand tu le massacré tu vois et tiltait
donc il s'arrêtait quoi tu perdais ta
partie quoi
moi j'ai que la que la rêve du poker
voilà je savais pas et ben écoute
j'ai pas encore enfin le flipper ouais
c'était pas vraiment à la mode chez moi
non bah c'est plus trop la mode
maintenant mais si tu veux
est-ce qu'on peut bouffer 3 là allez on
y va là on bouffe 3 on verra après non
ouais c'est chaud de voir après mais bon
3 je prends G6
[Musique]
en pratique
tout recettes c'est pas mal c'est dans
la même veine
il est gagnant mais bon il faut qu'il
finisse il y a 5 secondes
il va poser des problèmes ça va être
chaud F6
bien joué bien joué très très bien joué
maintenant
qui joue très vite mais va gagner cette
position avec l'option F7 avec quelques
secondes à la pendule
c'est bien il s'est il s'est enlevé des
problèmes
on va voir il met les pions sur les
bonnes cases il faut pas faut pas
craquer
fait bien sûr
[Musique]
il mérite entièrement son point
j'ai joué hyper vite
attention
c'est dangereux il va aller chercher B2
se mettre derrière est-ce que ça va
suffire quand il va lui choper
c'est pas simple même cela elle est pas
simple franchement non non non
la barre qui remontait quand même
et maintenant c'est mieux mais ok il y a
y a plus de feuilles
a elle arrive à faire
c'est quoi
joue vite hein continue à jouer vite des
échecs des échecs des échecs des échecs
[Musique]
important le niveau c'est affolant bah
tu vois de la caméra c'est le numéro 1
c'est le numéro 1 et ça va faire nul
cette partie
ça va faire nul
attends j'ai 8 ça ne marche pas il y a
échec intermédiaire bien joué par avion
quand même c'est bien
à proposer incroyable franchement quelle
défense des deux joueurs parce que les
deux joueurs franchement
pouvez essayer
quand même c'est un super joueur en fait
de Bullet
donc ça se fait du coup combien un et
demi c'est ça non
est-ce qu'il avait gagné une partie où
c'était une nul
il avait fait
bien ça le ennemi ça j'aime bien ce
petit et demi
je suis complètement fou il fait mal
celui-là
mais bon en 1 + 1 bah il faut qu'il
prenne 0 pour moi
[Musique]
en fait je pense que je suis foutu
la pose du 3 minutes en plus là après
donc ouais mais j'ai mes baril était
très mauvais en fait
complètement d'accord avec moi avec toi
je suis époustouflé par la vitesse
justement Bullet etc et là lucidité
c'est vrai dans certaines positions il a
pas réussi à convertir par Aviane mais
c'était du Beaujeu quand même oui mais
Nakamura qui se bat comme
moi il est hors concours pour moi c'est
à dire que c'est juste
ces choses qu'il arrive à faire
[Musique]
une fois tu vois il joue que tu veux
bizarre que des trucs mais bon ils sont
fous il est là il défend
tu vois là par exemple C3
ça a l'air très très dur déjà pour les
mais maintenant il se bat
en tout cas il réfléchit pas mal quand
même
parce que quand il a du temps au
parabane il est vraiment pas maladroit
il pose beaucoup de problèmes
il y a des réflexions c'est juste avant
d'avoir quelques secondes des fois où il
cherche un peu trop waouh
c'est chaud
[Musique]
il m'en fous
il rigole il sait que ça va pas être
forcément très sérieux
[Musique]
et il faut prendre
bah c'est un peu mieux je crois pour les
Noirs ils conserve même des chances de
faire quelque chose
ouais j'ai 6 places
j'aurais au pire je peux prendre et
prendre mais dans le B7 quand même moi
je sais pas mais même qui existe un coup
qui se regarde je pense effectivement
c'est intéressant
on avait commencé par cavalier 6 Charles
c'était très intéressant
cavalier C5 dans le même style
les menaces de maths quand même qui
était quand même assez désagréable
il faut faire gaffe parce qu'il est
capable de le bouffer c'est à dire faux
set si on faisait si on
si on se prend un moment à cavalier F6
et le pion des cartes en l'air faire
gaffe
il est trop marrant après il y a des
gens qui n'aiment pas parce que il est
un peu
trop
il est tellement fort bon il faut que tu
n'aimes pas trop
comment tu es
mais si j'aime beaucoup rigoler mais des
fois tu vois ça peut être à la limite de
les respects c'est toujours le truc bon
on en est pas
comment dirais-je c'est qui c'est
abandonné
bon là c'est un peu exagéré mais bon on
voit bien que là ça charit quoi bon
après c'est les échecs sur Internet
c'est souvent beaucoup plus
non
mais en plus c'est sûr qu'il le ferait
peut-être pas tu vois parce que pas la
viande j'ai pas trop envie j'ai pas trop
envie de l'embêter tu vois
ce que je l'embête avec tout référent
d'ailleurs tout refaire
par contre
faut que je fasse gaffe non mais faut
que je fasse gaffe à chaque fois quand
il est pas un cavalier F3 ça doit être
gagnant cette position
et attention je peux tout manger
tout manger en dessin qui est faire
cavalier 3 ou pas
alors le gain il s'obtenez comment
comment vous avez tourné 8 et en tout
cas
on peut peut-être vous le montrer hein
cette seconde compte 26
obligé pour faire un truc à la rage plus
de temps et perdu
après c'est facile à dire
[Musique]
ça suffit pas
hyper rapide pour tout bouffer avec 18
secondes hyper facile
moi j'aimerais bien là dans cette
deuxième partie de trois plus un il
fasse une très très belle partie qui en
gagne une il a l'air dépité pourtant tu
vois c'est quand même dur que nous on
est content pour lui parce qu'il gagne
une partie de mais
en fait c'est dingue parce que l'énergie
qui doit mettre dans ses parties par
avion tu vois Hikaru et là il rigole ils
sont fous tu vois mais par avion il met
tout son énergie et au final c'est dur
quoi c'est dur moralement et c'est dur
aussi
à tout point quoi tu vois physiquement
c'est dur aussi
donc je crois
du coup les gars on va faire une petite
pause 3 minutes on revient on revient à
l'instant pour du coup le dénouement de
ce 7 en 3 + 1
pour l'instant du coup
173 et demi pour Nakamura donc c'est
difficile c'est très difficile
en tout cas tout de suite et récemment
ne partez pas petite pause qui est petit
truc à manger après on revient allez à
tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on est reparti dans ce speechestre
avec
qui attendent que ça reprenne ma caméra
qui a buggé
il voulait pas reprendre sans nous
ouais c'est ça
et va réussir à à mettre les quatre
points et demi
ça va être difficile pour moi je pense
mais bon
c'est pas c'est pas ridicule j'ai quand
même beaucoup de réussite dans le match
d'avant donc
ouais
c'était cher
oui parce que en fait dominateur mais à
chaque fois c'était un petit point quoi
voilà en même temps là dans dans ce qui
est un petit peu déconnant c'est qu'il y
a une sacrée livraison ah tu me diras ça
s'équilibre avec la partie de parabian
en fait parvient à donner un demi point
d'accord et n'a qu'à donner un point à
un point entier ce qui lui arrive quand
même pas trop dans ces cadences là quand
il s'est pris le truc avec damage 4
ils sont ils s'en fout un peu et encore
une orang-outan pour
quand ça me fait réviser par Aviane
[Musique]
aussi on sent que c'est pas
il le sait très bien
il le sait très très bien
mais ça reste solide
et donc paire de fou pour les Noirs
meilleurs contrôle du centre mais plus
de pions ensemble pour les blancs
et puis on DC sont embêtant
donc il faut jouer simple
il faut jouer assez rapidement parce que
Naka il est il est terrible dès que dès
que vous n'avez plus de temps et vous
abuse
il faut des trois là infiltration why
not
un petit B6 à un moment pour sécuriser
baisses
et laissez la dame à avoir tout le champ
il a du mal à le jouer c'est un petit
peu bizarre parce que
il a toujours pas joué il veut pas le
jouer
[Musique]
et après j'essaie de pousser pour B4 je
vais pour B4 mais bon c'est pas si
facile
ça fait structure de ragozyme un petit
peu de gambidamragosine ok c'est Kate et
le jeu à l'eldame E4 est difficile à
jouer facilement il y a plus assez de
pièces
là ou alors il veut laisser l'attention
mais bon c'est logique je pense
on met pour B8 on joue pour B4 comme B4
mais
pas trop
le contre-jeu c'est E34 je veux dire on
regarde les sommets de structure et on
garde donc le sommet des 4 on pousse à
côté E4 et sommet C4 on pousse à côté
des cartes bon B4
Adama peut-être punaise j'ai tombé
ici maintenant c'est un peu plus
difficile à calculer tu sais à cause de
prise B4 je me dis que sur le long terme
je calme une pure passée protégée et que
je peux récupérer je peux essayer de
mettre la pression tu vois c'est vrai
mais j'allais jouer comme par avion de
B4 mais c'est sans doute un principe tu
vois il aurait pas dû laisser le contre
je crois
qui pouvait préparer tout peut-être avec
tour B6 en premier pour proposer
l'échange de la tour à 6 et après
et après je vais pour B4
je pense que
en fait il avait vu un truc quoi il a dû
rater en fait dans la cadre je pense
ouais
juste avant mais c'est trop tard déjà
quand vous allez jouer B4 de voir dans
ma carte
il est pas mal il est pas mal le Pavard
mais il est quand même un petit thé de
voir les carroscopes il aurait aimé
faire mieux
pendant ce temps ça se passe bien
[Musique]
en train de chanter
plus de plus de gains
mais ce qui est incroyable c'est que
il y a un petit grain de sable qui se
met à chaque fois dans le dans le moteur
et Pam il se la fait coller direct dès
qu'il y a une demi bêtises quoi
terrible
et puis maintenant c'est 40 secondes
contre une minute 40
et là c'est foutu en fait il y a un pion
net de moins
plus la minute là par avion va jouer
pour pour essayer mais à part une énorme
gaffe on est on est dans le mal
dommage parce qu'il avait fait le
travail
ça va lui faire du mal celle-là
il en reste encore combien de parties
deux après celle-là normalement
ouais
je vise quand même je vise quand même un
perfect de Nakamura pour essayer de
t'appeler le choix 1 + 1 c'est comme
aléatoire une défaite est vite arrivé
bon je pense que je suis
je pense que je suis max de chez Max de
en fait en vrai c'est un max 4 seul que
je peux prendre mais je pense que je
crois que tu peux prendre
si jamais de la vie
tu gagnes le match et tu et en plus il
fait zéro
en plus un ou un demi un demi et faire
un devis en fait
ah oui
ça va être abondant
non mais je suis je peux je suis mal là
je pense au mieux pour moi c'est lui de
pour toi et 10-0 qui est fort probable
c'est chaud ça dépend ça dépend
de ce petit
une sorte de laiton qui a été joué hein
par les trois cavaliers du coup
c'est parti
et ouais mais la caméra est doucement
vraiment trop trop à la légère et
voilà
allez David c'est le moment
c'est le moment
tout se prendre
donc du coup cavalier 6 c'est quoi c'est
une pression juste énorme en fait kf6
dans H4
tu me regardes
attends est-ce que j'ai droit de jouer
il y a encore
faut pas perdre tout ton temps
ça tu me gagne pas celle-là je vais pas
être content
[Musique]
au final je m'en fous quoi mais ok
l'idéal c'est qu'il fasse zéro pour moi
surtout le long voire
un coup
je pense qu'il va la finir celle-là
celle-là je pense qu'il va la finir
pourquoi
il va le trouver le pourquoi je pense il
a que deux coups de toute façon ça ou ça
ça c'est pas si sûr que ça m'attend
c'est ça ça
c'est parfait comme par exemple
[Rires]
c'était énorme c'était énorme c'était
Archimède
je me suis pris une crasse quoi
bon en tout
[Musique]
casinette de plus non tu as une pièce de
moi
du coup on fait quoi comment on finit
bah c'est pas si simple l'histoire hein
c'est bien nul c'est
donc il va se la faire coller en plus
[ __ ] c'est pas vrai
je pense qu'il va pas perdre
il a une minute il sait qu'il l'a laissé
un peu filer
c'est le contexte psychologique et pas
le même quand tu laisses filer un joueur
comme d'accord
il faut que tu as sur cheeseccom tu vas
dans le profil de Naka auparavant
et
puis même sur le sur l'événement
speechess tu l'auras
tu peux trouver de partout
apparemment
peut-être ça marche
qui va se cacher il s'enjaille
en C6
quand même parce que sinon après il joue
vite aussi
c'est tempo pour mettre la pression mais
du coup il fait des fautes
ah c'est chiant peut-être
ouais
5 et c'est bien ouais
c'est ce qui va jouer de trouver
[Musique]
on fait machin
c'est un truc de fou
c'est un truc de fou il était
complètement son roi il a fait je sais
pas combien de coup je pense en 37 coups
de la partie ils sont là les bougies
peut-être 20 fois
là il prend tous les pions il perd ses
trois ouais c'est fini
quelle machine quelle machine
quelle machine à 4h30 ça va être abandon
j'ai senti qu'il allait à paumé en plus
punaise
c'est hallucinant complètement
hallucinant
et après tu dois retourner avec moi le
mec qui vient de te faire ça
franchement le mec qui te il te vole
comme pas possible et boum à trois quoi
de ce genre de de Sénart de faut rester
j'aurais du mal quand même à supporter
ça tu vois et par Aviane il est beaucoup
plus habitué que nous à gagner encore
donc
il est c'est un grand joueur
professionnel et se prendre ça ça reste
quand même difficile et robinside a dit
la violence et oui d'accord qui rigole
c'est chaud c'est chaud
dans les ouvertures jusqu'à gagnant
après il a compris le Sénat il arrête
pas de se mettre mal au temps aussi
stouf même si il joue très bien amulette
par Aviane
on voit que Naka si tu laisses du temps
d'avance gare roi des deux tu vois il va
juste te dire bah vas-y je vais
réfléchir regarde
il joue pas
il est complètement taré en fait et bien
tu vois et tout ça c'est ça m'a perte
quoi c'est moi qui paye les cèpes
derrière de ce que fait c'est moi qui
paye les chefs de Naga quoi ça se fait
pas ça
il est pas très sérieux il est vraiment
niveau troll et c'est ouf
découverte
j'ai 4 H3
mais quasiment là il y a des idées avec
bien sûr tour des 8 ou grand rock pour
jouer pour cavalier C4 mais c'est pas si
facile que ça apparaît en plus il est
extrêmement mal et là maintenant il
commence à dire mais qu'est-ce que je
suis nul c'est de la merde alors que tu
cherches quand même vachement pas trop
mal quand même excuse-moi tu cherches
ils s'entraîne à arnaquer c'est bien dit
deux c'est une manœuvre assez assez
modeste
mais c'est pas débile en plus tu vois il
est en mode
un gros F5 bien grave là tu as envie de
lui envoyer mais lui c'est ce qu'il
demande
le Spirit bravo quand même ce que fait
par avion il se dit il se démobilise pas
le gap à ravial
dans la tronche hein parce que il vient
quand même de se prendre un coup dur
comme il a l'habitude dans ce match mais
je suis d'accord avec Steve long grand
spectacle allez F5 niveau mental c'est
assez fort ce qui fait là je trouve que
par avion c'est mieux ce qui fait parce
qu'il est quand même beaucoup plus
rapide tu vois il est vraiment dans le
bon move allez FG on réfléchit pas ainsi
voilà allez tac
j'ai pas le poids
le petit
le petit jeu alors j'ai trois j'ai trois
c'est pas mal parce que où va le roi sur
G3
pour un jour pouvoir ouvrir encore plus
en cas droit géant
mais c'est bien aussi raison avec
laquelle tour tu nous as pas dit ici
quand même
j'ai un bien joué
non mais c'est incroyable je comprends
pas je comprends rien
tout reprend parce qu'il profite du
clouage et du Fou aussi ce qui va être
perdu en fait
c'est un truc de fou tu es complètement
gagnant et d'un coup tu as fait une
imprécision dans ton attaque il y a plus
rien
il est vraiment il est vraiment au
dessus c'est un truc de fou mais voyez
là là il est en mode en mode clown quoi
on le verra au prochain tour au prochain
tour il va affronter à rognan Nakamura
et bah il fera pas 50 à revenir il vous
garantis qu'il jouera pas jouera pas des
débuts comme il fait maintenant
après
l'équilibre c'est hallucinant
mais paramètres
c'est une bonne chose parce que
en grande difficulté et puis il se fait
il se fait ré-attaquer puisque Naka il a
décidé de l'enfler donc peut-être fouder
ça ici
la position et c'est dur au niveau tu
vois au niveau enfin je veux dire
à chaque couille banane ça fait trois
heures que ça dure
psychologiquement il est vraiment dur il
est vraiment dur à jouer d'accord
il faut vraiment être alerte tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps
mais on peut pas jouer bon est-ce que on
fait un tour G8 quelque chose comme ça
attention on te reprend B7 pour tout le
monde donc c'est si peut-être c'est ce
qu'on peut jouer
plus de menace ouais et du coup tourgé 8
on sent qu'il y a des possibilités
quand même
ça va perdre parce qu'il y a trop de
pions
[Musique]
c'est pas vrai quoi
il fait ce qu'il peut David
et il va rester du coup une dernière
partie je pense après celle-là qui reste
2 minutes sur le temps additionnel
et par avion qui est qui est il était en
plus il fait de son mieux il essaie
vraiment de bien jouer aux échecs
c'est terminé
dernière partie à cette portion
il faut y aller à la dernière partie tu
sais on se motiver
donc
il faut jouer H4 très fort pour moi
c'est assez logique parce que souvent je
dis faire la le coca va laisser 3 pour
faire A4 en cas de B5 quand t'as pas le
cavalier en C3 ça c'est le thème mais
ouais quel enfer Robin side infernal et
arrogant pas faux
David nous met 100 à 10 je sais pas
combien il nous met mais je pense qu'il
nous met
il est très fort apparemment il m'amène
quand même d'accord sur certaines
séquences
maintenant on a qu'à s'accroche
tellement bien qu'il arrive à le
roi comme ça
c'est quoi X dans machine E4 et on avait
les compenses OK
il est moins gagnant que d'habitude dans
le début
David on a l'impression d'habitude des
ouvertures complètement fantasques
là ok la pierre Tiger ça reste une
ouverture
et d'ailleurs là direct il y a pas
davantage pour une fois pour
pour parabian
du coup peut-être qui va lui coller quoi
donc il reste 20 secondes dans ce
deuxième set avant de passer après au
Bullet
c'est très très dur pour par avion qui
passe un sale quart d'heure
ce qui marque des points et marque des
points mais au final
il a jamais jamais été sérieux il a joué
tout et n'importe quoi
et du coup c'est dur
c'est dur
en 30 minutes
sur Tesla sur Obs tu vois afficher 30
minutes
un petit peu tu penses que je dois
il va attendre que paravient de ce même
mal au temps et puis lui mettre des
embrouilles maintenant le plan est
beaucoup plus
bravo stuff trouvé mais bon
il tricote il attend que comme tu l'as
dit que par exemple maintenant
le match
il essaye pas forcément de jouer tous
les meilleurs coups mais il veut juste
on sait jamais le Pione peut bouger on
reste en face
peut-être voilà jouer et peut-être F4 on
verra bah non pas F4 parce que Nakamura
est pas de stabila
tout simplement
c'est bien pénible non il est venu à 5
ok bon maintenant on peut rebouger la
dame peut-être en E3 ou pas faire
quelque chose pas évident
allez parviennent des coins parce que là
c'est trop long
et pas grand chose pour les blancs parce
que c'est très risqué le roi est un peu
faible
donc je vois bien je le voyais revenir
bon j'ai pas de perspective quoi je
m'ennuie
je m'ennuie ça va avec les Blancs et je
vois mon temps c'est grainé
[Musique]
si vous voulez je vais plus pour des
échanges particuliers pour chambouler la
position pas des structures
particulières il y a pas de rupture
réelle
donc c'est
[Musique]
c'est dur quoi
maintenant se mettre dans une dynamique
après Bullet et ça ira mieux
mais là dans la dynamique 3 plus c'est
trop dur
il a essayé de bien faire d'habitude il
y a une livraison dans l'ouverture qui
ne suffit pas forcément mais là il y a
pas eu la livraison et du coup c'est
chaud
par rapport à ce que tu dis
mais en fait maintenant je pense enfin
je sais pas de défendre encore une fois
parce que je trouve ça pas très correct
non plus mais
maintenant c'est un peu la nouvelle
génération avec tout ce qui est twitch
les réseaux sociaux tout ça et je pense
qu'en fait
[Musique]
enfin je sais pas comment dire mais
il s'adapte à la demande quoi après bon
les gens aiment bien un peu
le côté le côté tout ça et du coup je
pense que c'est ce qui fait en fait et
c'est je pense pas que de de base c'est
vraiment une mauvaise personne ni
quelqu'un qui qui aime se moquer des
gens etc mais en fait je pense juste
qu'il
[Musique]
il a beau trollé des fois il fait des
trucs mais car ça jamais jouer à 4
jamais ils jouent un truc comme ça
et
c'est absolument rien et puis il y a
joué entre il y a joué un truc mais à
l'attitude c'est plutôt l'attitude qui
est voilà plus plus
à 14h30 là dans cette dans cette partie
du coup je suis encore en cours
qui sont encore en course mais ça va
dépendre si il m'a juste un point en
Bullet je suis complètement mais une nul
c'est bien
0 c'est bien une nul c'est bien un point
ça met complètement dedans un et demi
aussi et deux jeunes enfin
ça va me en tout cas je suis quand même
très mal hein au niveau des subs oh
mieux
et là dans la partie
très très mal au temps et là il va jouer
très probablement B4 et puis on passe
très très belle partie quand même de
d'accord avec cette poussée B4 quand
même très propre
rabais 5
il a plus qu'à pousser le pion
maintenant
j'allais montrer pourquoi mais
parti annuler je peux pas avancer
pourquoi je pense si je fais non je
pense je peux pas faudrait que tu ailles
chercher dans les archives parce que du
coup s'il faisait à 3 il y avait tout
reprend cavalier parce que le fou
faisait une
laser qui est très née mais il a été
attentif du coup 7 et demi un demi dans
7 portions de
2-3+1 ce qui fait un score de 14,5 pour
Nakamura normalement dans la suite c'est
de 1 et demi 1 sauf
[Musique]
ça fera 10 euros
du coup alors moi je vais vous changer
ça
si vous voulez dans une petite pause 3
minutes
3 minutes de pause et pour les deux
super voilà le meilleur de Bullet
là il y aura pas de pause par contre
pour ces Bullet ça va aller directement
jusqu'au finish et puis et puis et puis
voilà donc
savourer je suis pas sûr qu'il se rend
compte ou pas je pense que je pense
qu'après ce match il va aller sortir la
bouteille
[Musique]
voilà à tout de suite une petite pause
restez là on arrive dans quelques
minutes à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour pour cette
dernière portion
de match en une plus une ça va être
chaud
va sombrer totalement ou va se refaire
ambulette contre un aka trop chamber
c'est ça alors je vais en profiter déjà
avant de de commencer cette petite
finale de Bullet vous envoyez quand même
petite pub de nos chaînes respectives
vous savez que tous les deux Kevin et
moi et ben on a des sites internet on a
aussi des twitchs et donc je vais vous
envoyer nos publicités donc Kevin et
stream assez je sais pas que quelle
fréquence régulièrement souvent le
mercredi soir et le vendredi soir
et voilà on a plein d'infos de toute
façon voilà n'hésitez pas à aller
visiter notre site internet venir nous
voir quand on est en stream
respectives avec grand plaisir allez
voir allez voir Kevin là je vous ai mis
le lien par contre Kevin je ne peux pas
me faire de shoutout
à moi-même moi je peux le faire oui il
faut que tu fasses point d'exclamation
bon ça Esso
espace stuff avec deux U
et ça me fait marcher
on s'en fout des majuscules ok c'est pas
important voilà merci à toi donc pour
ceux qui auraient envie ceux qui ne nous
connaissent pas et ben en stream chacun
sur nos chaînes donc n'hésitez pas à
venir nous voir donc moi je stream
généralement tous les jours du lundi au
vendredi et de temps en temps le weekend
là avec le speech quasiment tous les
jours je vous ai dit que j'ai pas eu le
temps de stream à ça prend beaucoup
d'énergie
donc donc voilà en tout cas n'hésitez
pas à venir nous voir
j'ai fait pas mal de pas mal de
de match et on a aussi on a aussi la
chaîne Youtube
c'est Pro Évolution
c'est pareil et là on voit Nakamura qui
a 3000 342
mais Nakamura à 3342 les gars
on va avoir envie
de 2600
du coup en fait c'était pas mal
en tout cas vous voyez quelle prise
d'initiative ils font tous les deux
matchs donc il y a une demi-heure de
Bullet donc pour plus gagner un bon
Paris il faut que par avion soit marque
plus de points dans cette
dans cette portion ou alors qui ont
remarque moins
moins de 1/2 oh Shrek positif de cette
histoire donc ça va ah oui mais très
positif là ça dépend ça dépend du score
ouais si jamais il se prend Fanny dans
ce set où il marque un seul demi point
et bah ça fera que 6 4 voilà alors que
si il marque moins un peu plus
de d'un demi point
tu peux tu peux en prendre bref
Caro c'est quand même très très chaud à
battre c'est hyper ça joue hyper vite
c'est hyper vif 40 20 secondes et c'est
le classico
d'ailleurs j'ai lu j'ai eu un petit truc
de tout à l'heure de de
Nakamura je l'ai vu sur sur facebook
apparemment il disait que si il commence
la portion populaire à moins de ça veut
dire qu'il est mené de deux points avant
les Bullet et ben il pense qu'il est
favori que n'importe qui dans le monde
enfin ambulatoire et bon du coup voilà
même compte 45 si la -2 et ben il pense
qu'il favorit si rentre en Villette
c'est le meilleur joueur du monde à
cette cadence là ouais mais bon il y a
encore une fois il y a un incrément donc
c'est pas tout à fait
il a quand même trois pions de plus
toujours à la pendule en fait
une bulle ça va défiler je pense
que de défiler
foue F4 qui est 6
donc là il joue plus on a qu'à moi
comment il a une bonne souris
une boule à l'intérieur la caméra mais
en tout cas
en tout cas je pense que tu fais pas de
souci pour lui je pense qu'il est bien
voilà il se met bien un moment avec sa
souris je pense
[Musique]
ça peut arriver
pour ouvrir un peu la position
ok en tout cas c'est très bien joué des
deux côtés est-ce que par exemple va nul
parce que là c'est difficile de faire
mieux on est sous pression quand même
les blancs
tout bien ça tient prise pour C2
le 5 c'est pas grave il y a trois
et voir un peu ce qui peut menacé
il va le tourner il y a une pression au
temps quand même
il joue celle-là avec FC attention le
roi qui se met un petit peu en rose
pour travailler peut-être vos trois
tours
on peut rien faire on attend on fait
trois
tours à 3 allez on joue des petits coups
faut que j'arrive à te
sortir ce roi d'ici
c'est normal je pense peut-être à tour
là tour là qui paraît et tomber 6 sans
doute et nul
[Musique]
droit G3 elle en est proche d'une nulle
ok
il essaie de
attends
attention là il faut faire un petit peu
attention les Noirs ont beaucoup joué
non
il a craqué il abandonne
du coup voilà j'ai perdu sur le score
j'ai perdu sur le corps score final donc
maintenant il faut que je crois
en anticipation il a fait fou G4 quand
même par avion
une victoire de paraviane pour te sauver
dans les 20 prochaines minutes
il faut au moins un point de plus
un point de plus qui peut me sauver
sinon ça va être zéro la vie maintenant
on peut se relâcher c'est super ce que
tu as fait jusque là
un petit peu quand même
c'est assez bien trouvé des cartes quand
même
[Musique]
le bordel et avoir E4 D5 dans la finale
bah c'était tentant je me demandais si
on pouvait le faire au moins tu fais
gamberger
il a atteint apparemment
comment il va sortir du pétrin si
personne là
si personne là et ben nos Paris sont
terminés
quand même
et peut-être
en lui aussi quel quartier bien joué
dans ma carte il a envie de jouer un
Bullet où il est mal mais pas avec les
dames et le roi arrachées
le matin
jusqu'à présent
malgré tout
une énorme partie mais c'est vraiment
hyper dur il y a quelqu'un qui met une
pression
[Musique]
il a plus de temps roi et faim
qui buggait normalement c'est bon votre
caméra qui est revenu et voilà il a
collé deux fois de suite
stuffs
donc aujourd'hui on s'est pris 9 1 et 8
dans la tronche exactement
je sais plus comment ça fait tu me diras
un score final
[Musique]
score final e5c5 c'est quoi ça alors
c'est perdu
une pièce
qui se fait remonter angulaire
tu vas faire du bien à part Aviane quand
même de finir sur cette note là
de les piquer la Manche ce serait beau
quand même
pour l'instant il risque de passer à
trois quand même
très bon
[Musique]
qui bouge à lèvres je pense qu'il chante
il doit être la musique sûrement en même
temps
tout le temps pour l'instant ça va
les blancs c'est ah excusez-moi j'ai
oublié de changer merci beaucoup
désolé les gars je vous ai mis la
mauvaise la mauvaise c'était par avion
les blancs excusez-moi
excusez-moi
est-ce qu'on change la vue est-ce que
vous voulez une vue spéciale sur la tête
de Naka à la tête de parabian
en gros plan ouais si vous voulez j'ai
poli des folies techniques je peux vous
mettre moi après la partie parce que je
peux vous faire changer à chaque fois
avec le faire retourner trois
tu es prise au dos c'est chaud
prise de d'abord
du coup j'ai toujours faux F8 sur
ça il est retourné à maintenant
on peut plus rien faire voilà il y a
jamais dans
pas avoir
il met trop la pression c'est incroyable
quand même ça marchera
[Musique]
donc du coup maintenant il va perdre
tranquillement
la Dame des deux change et on joue la
halle
ça va être abandon de suite je vais vous
mettre l'autre l'autre vue juste pour
voir vous me dites à laquelle vous
préférez je vous mettrai la vue la vue
avec les deux grandes caméras des
joueurs aïe aïe aïe et là maintenant le
pion h il file vite le pion il est
contrôlé par le pion h
et depuis on a chalet plus vite que le
pion a dites moi ce que vous préférez la
vue est-ce que vous préférez celle que
je viens de vous mettre où est-ce que
vous préférez la vue avec nos têtes
dites-moi un Néandertal je m'attends au
pire j'irai voir
les quatre
ça promène ça doit être de la bonne
je pense qu'il préfère notre tête et on
les moi je pensais aussi je pensais
aussi du coup je vous la remets belle
ouverture du carreau c'est grâce à Kevin
ça c'est grâce à ta
beau gosse
comme dans un cauchemar pour parabian
qui va se faire
pas mal
[Musique]
à la fête
ça on voit du lourd merci à toi Alexine
de participer à ce spectacle
c'est gentil merci pour les mots sympas
c'est chaud aujourd'hui demain je
grandes qualités franchement c'est bien
régalé ok on a passé du temps après 8h
de direct avec stuff mais c'est vrai que
le speechestre ça passe hyper vite il y
a tout le temps des choses qui se
passent c'est hyper dynamique donc le
format a commenté est super sympa
on a encore un match après t'as pas
oublié
après là ce soir on a un troisième match
ce soir
de me prévenir
à partir de 15 heures pour le premier
quart de finale entre Ding et Sarine
farine qui a joué hier déjà fou c'est 4
comment
Aires
faut prendre
quel génie
d'accorder comme ça ça fait peur
ça fait peur
je crois en Bullet dans 3 2 pardon pour
il veut pas perdre je pense ça doit
l'embêter quand même
[Musique]
d'autant plus que bon il y avait quand
même la marge
et normalement c'est sa cadence un peu
de prédilection
il s'est fait vraiment bouger
[Musique]
donc là il y a déjà des problèmes sur
les cases noires ici attention
prise dessin ça fait peur pour les deux
il va faire un joli score quand même par
rapport à nos pronostics
et au final là il est à 5 et demi pour
l'instant et c'est pas fini
c'est pas fini il peut encore en mettre
après il a pas jouer si sérieux que ça
et du coup ça aurait été encore bien
motivé pour faire le score fleuve tant
qu'on est les circonstances
parce que là pour le coup il a pas
fait une seule partie avec E4 D4 qui
avait F3 enfin il y a toujours fait à 4
B4 tu vois
H3 B4
tu vois c'était pas très
tombé de qui arrive tu auras deux qui
essaie de c'est un tour B8 qui est ces
deux qui peut arriver aussi
[Musique]
il y a pas de l'attention
la case heureusement mais bon
c'est quoi le coup de défense comment on
bloque
ça tient peut-être un histoire sûrement
vu la jauge ça va tenir
[Musique]
maintenant on peut pousser en plus on a
un plan simple de pousser le pion des
qu'on ferait pas un petit roi préventif
pour pas se prendre de crasse voilà
les petits tours
mais on sait qu'il y a rien
ne pas grand chose et par Aviane va la
coller en 1 0
c'est pas encore fini il faut encore
trouver les couilles
il a pris le risque d'aller dans le coin
direct sur ton baby je pense être le
plus simple
c'est la pizza nana chorizo peut-être
qui a flingué tout non mais j'ai mal à
baller ma salive
quel effet vous provoquer chez stouffe
c'est quoi cette position cascade nous
dit bon
à 55 secondes
mais la presse
avec la présence de joueurs comme
Nakamura Carson tout ça et donc le
premier tour c'est quand même censé être
mais derrière par contre des masques qui
vont arriver avec ma casse c'est juste
trop bien quoi
il est un peu long des fois comme là par
exemple ce match là trois heures c'est
un peu
c'est un peu quand même
de la moitié
[Musique]
en fait quand le match il est il est
trop
une heure une demi-heure c'est pas bien
sûr
et ben c'est long
position intéressante pour pour les deux
joueurs
sans doute la vie de parasiane et
beaucoup mieux mais c'est pas si facile
mais il a 40 secondes d'avance quoi
40 secondes d'avance ça se rencontre
une minute il le 34e coup il a 46
secondes contre 3 quoi c'est
complètement hallucinant enfin
[Musique]
c'est
sur les finales oui c'est pareil le
sablier après quand on aura d'autres
matchs ça sera toujours pareil
terrible il est en train de d'améliorer
avoir des petits trucs ou des cas
terminaux
il a pas besoin
elle plus que 8 minutes 50 dans ce match
terrible et paravient de se faire encore
hop
embourbé et ça fait maintenant 5 2 dans
ce
dans ce match alors cars ça fait combien
ça fait 23,7 c'est ça pour l'instant on
a 19,5
ans quand même en étant vraiment
extrêmement mal
après c'est le jeu
tu vois il
il est tranquille il est tranquille et
je joue tranquille de toute façon après
Carlson c'est pareil oui les personnes
tout le temps
alors que bon Nakamura il a jamais joué
une ouverture normale quoi complètement
franchement gros mérite je pense qu'on
parvient qui qui se bat et qui
abandonne pas tu vois parce que c'est
dur de se prendre des tôles des tôles
des tôles de tôle
qui joue à 4 à chaque partie
et qui de troll c'est c'est pas évident
mais
franchement on s'en sort bien et là il
arrive à jouer sans tilter il fait de
multiplié et
en tout cas par avion fait une très très
bon Bullet il met une énorme pression il
joue très vite là
un accord arrive encore à les trouver à
chercher des poux
j'ai trois rois F3 peut-être
tour des deux mais bon
stabiliser la structure tomber trois
très bien et cavalier 5 par la suite en
cas de problème
à chaque fois
[Musique]
et là maintenant ouais c'est foutu je
pense il y a vraiment peu de chance de
d'arnaquer à cette position
[Musique]
autant encore une fois
ce royaume
des pour gagner la partie là il va
manger ici
là c'est quand même perdant je pense
assez facile donc
c'est compliqué la vie moi tu vois
je pense pas
on s'en approche
c'était pas une bonne idée
parce que ce genre de choses
dans l'autre sens qu'on imaginait mais
non il est là par Aviana dans le dans le
Bullet pour ça a été énorme quoi il est
là
quand il dit qu'il est vraiment très
fort mais en fait il est tombé sur un
client ambulette hein heureusement qu'il
avait fait la différence avant parce que
sinon il y aura mais bon il y a
tellement d'écart et puis bon il a joué
il a joué light au niveau ouverture
bon on peut peut-être dire que c'est
aller à l'avant-dernière celle-là qu'il
va recoller
celle là je pense que
c'est énorme
en Bullet ça serait ça serait beau déjà
ce serait bosser une victoire
attention à la dame de David David il
peut se faire bananer attention des
cavaliers 5 et 5 la dame qui est même le
5 là maintenant
toutes les pièces sont un peu trapées
parce que même par exemple
du dessin
j'ai du cavaler des cadres il y avait
peut-être
G5 dame D6 E5 dame Descartes
on a vu la jauge donc ça m'indique qu'il
y avait un gain c'est pour ça que c'est
plus facile évidemment
qui avait peut-être pour gagner une
qualité
en tout cas
pas le foot paravient bien coincé on va
jouer dessus mais il avait tout pour
compenser sur la colonne
et il va ajouter deux pour essayer de
lutter que sur la colonne ouverte voilà
je sais pas comment il peut jouer c'est
pas facile un peu ouvert tu as juste
tours
mais c'est pas simple
[Musique]
et après son noir quand même
l'impression noir pour la colonne des
beaucoup de pièces noires
la pression est-ce que David va réussir
à rester à la pression au temps ça
commence à craquer un petit peu parce
que là il peut se faire encore tourner
côté il a que 15 secondes au temps pas
facile de prendre les décisions on peut
faire tout Noyal cavalier et faire mal
pas mal cette petite
tentative à les Leroy
des trois roquettes c'est pas facile de
choisir non plus pour Naka
pas mal c'est petite pression
parvient de très très rapide
là
30 secondes en fait
la fourchette qui qui transmet une
finale qui alors vraiment dur la finale
parce que de fout fait rien donc
du coup on peut facilement se faire
tourner
peut-être pas être gagnant mais pour
autant
c'est pas mal le setup avec le foie H2
il est pénible à gérer à cause du pion
[Musique]
E
F3
il reste 47 secondes
dans ce match est-ce que ce sera le
dernier parti parce qu'en front une
autre derrière
un peu
et avec les quelques secondes
c'est sûr que ça va ça va jouer d'accord
il a envie de l'embêter
il reste 19 secondes en ce match c'est
chaud
donc 50 coups potentiel je peux vous
dire que ça passe faire nul comme ça il
y aura peut-être un drame au temps et il
reste trois secondes
le temps additionnel est terminé et
voilà attention dernière partie
du match
est-ce qu'il va tenir ça
peut-être le 7e point donc vraiment sur
les bases de ce qu'on a vu entre ouais
globalement
donc ça
on a l'impression que ça devrait faire
nul ça répète quand même pas mal ouais
mais là par avion ça y est la gober un
pion donc il va peut-être essayer lui
aussi à son tour voilà il va essayer un
petit F6 un moment mais je suis pas sûr
que oui ça
il a complètement craqué
pour finir ce speech il doit être bien
vert Nakamura et voilà
c'est fini on va pas être malheureux
quand même de se dénouement non 5 4
ambulettes et
[Musique]
voilà 5 4 du coup par avant qui
c'est bien battu ambulette
donc franchement impressionnant cette
partie de Bullet
déjà il a pas réussi à faire plus de
comptes par avion donc il va quand même
ravaler un petit peu
qu'il a dit ça fait un peu mal ça quand
même c'est clair mais tu vois
en tong et malgré tout
c'est vraiment bien régalé franchement
c'était cool aussi très agréable très
animé c'est parti
beau spectacle un beau spectacle
les tableaux de matchs qui vont qui vont
arriver dans les prochains jours à
commencer par demain donc déjà juste
pour voir le quart de finale en bas à
droite entre saut
absorfo et App Store off c'est conclu
par le gain de saut qui va rejoindre du
coup Maxime va chez Lagrave en quart de
finale et dans les 8e et ben c'est la
caméra de vous qui s'impose face à par
avion et du coup demain à partir de 15
heures jusqu'à 19h on aura le plaisir de
streamer avec Samir Robin et moi-même le
match de dingly Rennes contre nyalshine
donc demain demain match à 15h le reste
j'ai pas exactement le calendrier sous
les yeux mais je crois que ça repart
lundi et vous aurez la suite des matchs
donc Nakamura
on aura 45 Caravana et on aura chaud
mvl et tout ça du coup streamé
normalement par par Louis stream par
Kevin Bordy donc donc voilà
je vous remercie tous d'avoir suivi le
stream c'est cool merci à toi
à nous à nous parler sur sur le chat à
suivre l'événement c'était vraiment
hyper hyper cool merci à toi Kevin pour
pour avoir accompagné pendant tous ces
matchs c'était hyper cool moi c'est
hyper sympa comme d'hab souffre et merci
à tous ceux qui ont été très actifs tous
ceux qui nous ont suivis dans le chat
c'était vraiment vraiment cool des très
bons moments et du grand spectacle donc
on sera à nouveau avec vous pour
d'autres événements sur votre chat comme
un grand plaisir et bah on a hâte de
voir la suite avec dès demain les quarts
de finale qui débute avec tout fait Sami
vous allez passer un très bon moment
c'est certain c'est à partir de 15
heures donc toi et moi on se retrouve
quand même normalement
en janvier
fin décembre normalement juste après
Noël fin décembre voilà pour pour les
championnats du monde de rapides
donc donc voilà merci à tous est-ce
qu'on part avec un petit raid pour ça
bravo bravo tous vos aussi pour la
performance parce que mine de rien tu es
là depuis le départ moi j'avais mes
cours toi tu as vraiment beaucoup pas
vrai pour pour les streams mais du coup
grosse journée aujourd'hui et demain tu
remet ça bravo à toi toujours bonne
humeur le Gastou merci à toi et on y va
donc les gars on va faire un petit red
c'est un mec que vous ne connaissez pas
je pense parce que c'est pas un c'est
pas quelqu'un qui stream les échecs mais
bon il est hyper sympa franchement
aller le voir et faites du plein de gros
bisous il est hyper drôle moi je le vois
je suis mort de rire et hyper bonne
humeur donc voilà merci à tous à demain
pour ma part pour du coup ce
[Musique]
ce premier quart de finale entre so
entre digne et Sarine et à très très
bientôt les gars à bientôt salut ciao
qui va partir dans quelques secondes
donc merci à tous et à très très très
bientôt bonne soirée à tous ciao ciao
salut